[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
the racketeering rat
should we call him rack of Tootie I
don't know
rank a Tui racket racketeering Tootie I
don't know you know the movie I'm
talking about
the rank Cooks
I don't know maybe I should have put
that on the thumbnail who knows who
knows mafani Willis is hot on this rat's
heels
apparently she's gonna use the RICO the
RICO activate now we've we've known this
for a while this has been the suspicion
but apparently it's being more confirmed
this morning
at the Fulton County district attorney
Bonnie Willis is going to charge Donald
Trump
and his mob political mob like group of
nimika poop and Nazis
with a racketeering
I like to see his fat ass wiggle out of
that one
oh yeah and apparently apparently people
are really excited that he's gonna go on
trial next May folks I keep telling you
stop stop getting excited about this
I I believe that Canon judge Cannon
picked this particular date for a reason
and the reason that I've been telling
you
by May of next year Donald Trump is
probably going to have enough delegates
and there's going to be no one else who
can gather up enough delegates to be the
nominee for the Republican Party
she knows that he's been saying it out
loud for her to hear over and over and
over and over I'm gonna be the nominee
I'm the nominee I'm the nominee it's
only going to give him her more of an
excuse next year to punt this trial even
further and if you want any evidence of
this they've already punted the trial
once and they wouldn't they didn't
accept the date of December they moved
it past December
she is setting this particular date I
believe because she knows in May of next
year Donald Trump will be the obvious
nominee for the Republican Party
and it will be the reason why they pun
it past the election
you [__] doubt me go ahead go ahead
go ahead and be pissed off at me over
telling you what I believe to be the
reason why she's doing it and what's
probably going to happen I have personal
experience with punting criminal trials
in a federal system trust me they're
going to punt this thing they're going
to keep doing it it's the reason why she
said it in May
and I know I know I know you want him to
go on trial before the election I
understand the feeling I get that you
want accountability but the timing on
the documents case just doesn't lay out
that quickly
you got to remember the crimes that
they're that they're and they indicted
him on he committed last year
this isn't the January 6 case there's a
better chance that the January 6 case
will actually go to trial before the
documents case
and the reason why is because how far
the crimes back are committed and how
many people have been
indicted and convicted and sent to
prison for seditious conspiracy
nonetheless
so in this documents case don't get too
excited and if you're if you're
wondering why it's taking so long for
the January 6th case even Bonnie Willis
is just now bringing charges
of of [__] that happened prior to
January 6th
when he was pressuring the the Georgia
of the election officials
and they were they were using probably
state representatives in Georgia and
other political figures in Georgia to
try to try to steal the election in
Georgia that was in December of 2020.
and Bonnie Willis is just now bringing
charges it takes a bit to do this
these high level charges where they have
to have evidence in their hand
of a crime being committed it's not like
the January 6 [__] violent
insurrections where they had them on
camera they were live streaming their
[__]
so I know that it it's it sucks but we
have to be patient here for those
criminal cases we have to be
and besides even if you went on trial in
South Florida in the documents case in
the worst case scenario he's acquitted
because somehow they get trumpers on the
jury that absolutely will not say Donald
Trump is guilty no matter what even if
it's obvious without a shadow of a doubt
you don't think an acquitto in that case
next summer won't be a death blow to
democracy
[__] out of here get the [__] out of
here we need to be Trump's jury period
and we need to act like it
because the other the other thing about
the the left getting all excited that
Donald Trump's gonna go on trial before
the election and we'll get rid of him
and the justice system will save our
democracy is we're going to
self-suppress our own vote if we're not
careful people are going to get
discouraged people are going to get very
depressed maybe they won't believe in
the system
that's not what we need either
so you you have to stay vigilant and you
can't get your hopes up for no for for
anyone to save us but our ballot
stop acting like democracy Works
different than it does it doesn't work
differently now than it did in 2020. or
2016 for that matter
it is your job you as the voter you as
as the government
to go engage in your democracy and use
the ballot to determine what the
outcomes are it's not complicated it
really isn't
stop making it so complicated and stop
getting so damn excited about him being
in an orange jumpsuit I understand the
excitement I mean I can't wait I can't
wait really to see how they're going to
incarcerate him and how many places
they're gonna have to incarcerate him to
be quite honest it's [__] it's wild
[__] it's a wild time to be alive like I
said we're at the intersection in
WrestleMania in real life where these
[__] people are absolutely cheering
on the heel and they want the heel to
win
but that's where we're at that's that's
the weird ass timeline that we're in
and you're not going to change it and
neither is Jack Smith and neither is
Merrick Garland the only thing that we
can do is do our due diligence and our
democracy engage use our strategic
outrage to point it and win
against fascism that's what we have to
do
they're not going to save us
I mean for months people are like I'm a
God bear Garland get rid of him you need
to get rid of him and get someone who
will prosecute Trump
but you want them to save you stop it
it's up to us we must do this
We the People
and I know I keep pounding that message
but it's almost like people aren't
getting it yet
because everyone everyone on Twitter
this morning oh my God they're so
excited that Trump's finally got a trial
date oh Canon's actually gonna be a
judge she placed that date intentionally
think about think about what is going to
be happening in May of next year
we're going to be in a full-on
Republican primary in the May of next
year and almost all the delegates are
going to be already voted for
you don't think Eileen Gannon knows that
come on
come on get real
this is the person who tried to make
sure the special Master did what Trump
wanted and she didn't succeed
and this is the straw that we drew this
is how it works whether you like it or
not I don't like it but that's just
that's how it's going
so we must not get our hopes up now if
he goes on trial before the election
great I'll say I was wrong I'm glad I'm
wrong
but he's not gonna go on trial
Stop Believing the stuff that people are
saying that just doesn't make any sense
yes there's a date for trial but there
was already a date for the trial doj
asked for December
and she punted it to may think about why
she kicked it to May
if you're if you're sitting there
thinking that judge Cannon is doing the
right thing after watching what she did
in some of these decisions with the
special Master on this particular
documents case itself
if you don't think she's she's going to
do everything in her power
to make sure to legally give Trump what
he wants here
you're out of your mind
it's totally gonna do that she's totally
corrupt
she's totally inept
it's gonna happen
expect it
and if it goes better if it goes better
than what we expect I'll be excited
you'll be excited
but stop getting your hopes up
oh you thought I was gonna come on air
this morning be like I was wrong the
other's giving me a trial before the
elections it's gonna be great
ah you that's who you thought I was
gonna do didn't you you thought I was
gonna come on here and say
that I messed up that I was totally
wrong no because I'm not
my guess is that before the first of the
year maybe maybe even by January or
February they move this date again
the other thing that that maybe people
aren't thinking about is the tactics
that Donald Trump will use to delay
it is likely because this trial is set
in May so let's say it stays set in May
till March or April of next year he's
going to fire all his legal counsel and
he's going to hire all new legal counsel
it's what he's going to do
and they're going to argue well hmm
we're we need time to prepare for this
case
and Eileen Ken is going to you sure do
you sure do need time
it seems like we'll we'll kick this
Trail a little further I mean right now
they have plenty of time they go what 10
months 10 months to prepare for this
trial to to look at the evidence that is
obvious that their client is guilty as
charged
they got plenty of time to see that
so don't get too excited and don't get
too excited in your engagement about him
going on trial I'm telling you it's a
big huge strategic mistake and we don't
need any strategic mistakes right now
we don't
again you you really thought I was did
you guys think I was gonna come on here
and be like oh man oh man
I was wrong oh all of other people ride
and some people are asking about the
January 6 trial he's not even indicted
in the January 6th case yet
he's not even indicted now it looks like
it looks like we'll get an indictment
very quickly
for all accounts it seems as if Jack
Smith is going to make his move the same
way as the Fulton County D.A Bonnie
Willis is going to make her move here
all indications are that that's going to
be the movie even even the Attorney
General in Michigan made her move on the
uh the the fake Trump electors
in Michigan the 16 of them this week so
it's going to be reigning indictments
right
it's like an indictment storm coming
but that doesn't mean
but doesn't mean that the justice
department or the state Justice
departments are going to save our
democracy that is not their job their
job is to prosecute crime
that's their job let them do their job
we should do our job
we should do our job and make sure to
engage in our democracy use strategic
outrage
to make sure that we as a people come to
the ballot next November
and say no to trumpism loud and proud no
to authoritarianism absolutely [__]
not
take your authoritarianism and stick it
up your ass that's what this next
election needs to be about
and it already seems to be clear that
the messaging is there
I don't know if you noticed but Ron
DeSantis
um who was who was running for president
I I don't know what he's doing now
God he's horrible
horrible Ron DeSantis and by the way I
was right again Donald Trump last night
was was truthing about Vivek Rama Swami
yeah that's right vivec is a header on
DeSantis Trump is super excited that
Vivek is ahead of Rhonda santis in their
fake ass polls
I told you I've been telling you
that he's gonna be excited about bevec
being his opponent because Vivek is
intended to be his opponent in the
primary
listen I know you're like how in the
world is he always correct
I've been following politics for a long
time and I understand how Cults work the
other thing too is I understand how
these trumpers minds work
so whatever great analysis you're
getting somewhere else from commentary
go with the people who've been watching
who aren't blinded by clicks and and and
and and impressions
to go with the people who are just
sitting here and giving it to you
straight
not bullshitting you
what the f what the [__] does that it do
us to [__] you oh yeah he's gonna go
on trial he'll definitely be arrested
he'll definitely be imprisoned by the
time we elect Joe Biden again
it's not it's not it's not true it's
just not it's not how it's gonna happen
there is a two-tier justice system in
this country and Donald Trump is
afforded that privileged tear
he has been afforded it his whole life
now it's not protecting him anymore like
it used to but he still afforded it and
he's still gonna they're still gonna
give him
all the benefits that come along with
being in that top tier of Justice other
than just indicting him and trying him
trust me
it's there it exists it will what
happened that way they're letting him
run free he had thousands of classified
documents the evidence is that he was
showing them the people who did couldn't
see them
reality winner had one sheet of paper
one
one different case but only one sheet of
paper
and they arrested her immediately and
they didn't and they didn't release her
and tell her prison sentence was done
and she was still on house arrest after
that
so if you're wondering if we have a
two-tier justice system in this country
we do absolutely we do
you look at the disparity of of black
men put in prison for non-violent crimes
versus white men
there's a disparity there's a two-tier
justice system he's a beneficiary of it
they're only mad because it's not
protecting him anymore that's it that's
all they're upset about is that they
won't let him commit crime
without consequence that's what they're
mad about
so don't get your hopes up
doj will not save our democracy we will
save our democracy
in other news
uh Tony Bennett died
anyway 96 Tony Bennett's had dementia
for for a long time but he still I I
forget the interview that I watched but
he could still sing like that's one
thing that he could do
he could still he could still sing right
that's incredible even with the amount
of dementia because I think I think he
he didn't even really know most the time
who or where he was but he he could
still sing
which is incredible
um so and Tony Bennett one of the great
voice American voices
in our country I know there's going to
be a lot of people that are absolutely
uh torn apart by this uh some of his
great friends like Lady Gaga is torn
apart I know uh because she's a a dear
friend to Tony so but and you know it's
uh I I think uh he's 96 he lived a long
life he has a huge huge huge cache of of
content that we can uh love Tony Bennett
for the rest of History which is uh
which is a national treasure that we
have
um all those performances and recordings
of of Tony Bennett uh he was 96 I
believe and I know I know I can't
remember uh how long he's been suffering
from dementia but it's it's been a while
so but um what a hell of a life that
Tony Bennett had 96 uh um the music
career that spans spans damn near 100
years that's crazy
um so
shout out to Tony Bennett uh again a
national a National Treasure and again
you know the good news is that we don't
lose all of those memories of Tony
because we do have them recorded because
he was such a great artist such a great
singer so we have we have that cache of
of memories of Tony
so you know go out and enjoy it also the
the Barbie movie I'm gonna go see it
this weekend you know we talked about it
yesterday and a lot and apparently and
Gabe Sanchez said that as soon as the
movie comes on you'll know why
Republicans are pissed off which gets me
excited about watching this movie but
also uh the other movie that they're
talking about is Oppenheimer I want to
see that one too I don't know if I'll go
see both of them this weekend but I'm
definitely going to catch uh both of
these movies they're calling they're
calling the combination of the two
barberheimer I guess because some people
are watching the Barbie movie and then
directly going from that theater to
another theater and watching Oppenheimer
because they're saying that these are
two of the best films uh that's been
made in a while I I can't speak to it
because I haven't seen them but two
great great American stories believe it
or not
um in in Barbie
the Barbie story the Barbie doll now I
don't think the movie is about the
Barbie doll but it is it is Barbie
and then the the birth of the atomic
bomb this American story during the
second world war where Harry S Truman
used two atomic bombs
to
to end the war rather that's right wrong
or indifferent uh it is something that
we will evaluate in history but this
film uh
encapsulates
Oppenheimer
[Music]
coming up with the atomic Bond and and
developing it for us to use to end the
war
so but only only perpetuating
perpetuating us into the the situation
where we could have nuclear fallout and
over the entire world so
pros and cons to the
to the invention of the atomic Bond I
don't know if you know that but
that's supposed to be a great movie uh
one of the good great movies of this
year who knows how many movies we'll get
with the the strength going on but we'll
we'll see yes someone says the Manhattan
Project uh the Manhattan Project being
the project that developed the
the atomic bomb
but apparently that people are going and
watching Barbie and Oppenheimer like all
in the same sitting you know you go in
the theater
you go to the you know the one o'clock
showing of Barbie and then you go to the
four o'clock showing of Oppenheimer you
just walk from one to the other
barberheimer is what they're um it's
what they're calling it so and then
apparently the Barbie movie is just not
for children uh it's for everyone who's
had Barbie in their life or someone who
who you love has had Barbie in their
life that's why I'm going
yeah
that's why I'm going
it's because I I didn't I didn't even
really know Barbies even see Barbies
until my daughter was born I grew up
with uh just boys when we didn't have
girls in our family just boys right I
had no idea I never seen a Barbie
I we had Ninja Turtles and He-Man and uh
Power Rangers you know that sort of
stuff the action figures but never had a
Barbie I don't know didn't know anything
about it
so I'm excited to go see the uh the
Barbie movie other than just to come
talk about how it really pisses off the
right wing
isn't it funny
here's a movie about an iconic American
American classic Barbie
the empowerment of women I mean that's
what Barbie was that's what she is she's
the empowerment of women and and it's
changed throughout the decades the
empowerment it's become more inclusive
more diverse
in in more Dei and Barbie like over the
decades right
like they they you know
obviously uh Barbie is the picture
perfect but but they they have other
characters in Barbie and they release
those dolls to be more inclusive and
diverse
you know what you know what it probably
is you know what probably is I think
this is the reason why Ted Cruz and all
these right Wingers are mad is because
Ken doesn't have genitalia that's
probably what it is you know they're
obsessed with that they love to show
Hunter Biden's hog and Congressional
hearings I can't focus on anything but
genitalia this and genitalia that that
may be what they're upset about
is that Ken is just not anatomically
correct I guess maybe
and it hurts their manhood I don't know
I don't know all right if you're if
you're looking for why why Republicans
are mad about women's empowerment I mean
there's only one thing I can tell you
they they hate women they're anti-woman
I don't know if I don't know if I know
you picked up on that in the last couple
years Republicans hate women
duh no [__] Sherlock they want to ban
their health care they don't they don't
want them to vote I mean if they had
their way they'd make sure women
couldn't vote
they'd make sure that [__]
um someone says here Lacey says here in
in the chat uh weak men fear women
yes because women are better than men
I don't I don't know if I said that
enough here but
women are better than men they are the
better sex yes for sure 100 they are the
better sex they're smarter
they're more efficient
they they don't get dick brain
okay
you know what dick brain is that's what
the Republicans see and they continue to
have is Dick brain you know what I mean
you know what I'm talking about if you
don't know what I'm talking about I
don't know Google it
but women are so much better
so much better they're so much better
governing they're so much better at
being in charge they're so much better
at leadership they really are
men men want to pound their chest and
you know have dick measuring contests
right that's it that's all I want that's
that's the entirety of masculinity
it gets exhausting sometimes I don't
even really like hanging out with dudes
much anymore just because that's all it
is
how much power do I have and how big is
my my sausage is mine bigger than yours
it's [__] ridiculous
much rather hang out with women
they're prettier too they really are men
are ugly as [__] I mean there might be
some dudes that are pretty like Ryan
Gosling he plays can they might some of
them might be pretty ah most of us are
just [__] ugly
not that that
not that that matters
I guess it depends on who you are but if
you are and you're
and you're you should be here because
it's Friday
bonehead of the week and the second hour
Gabe Sanchez is going to join us at the
top of the hour and when he does we're
gonna go through bonehead of the week
you vote you decide who is the bonehead
of the week and we break it down in the
second hour of the show every single
Friday right here on YouTube so you're
not gonna wanna miss it so hit subscribe
right now hit the like button down below
I'm trying to get better at this YouTube
hit the like button down below subscribe
subscribe subscribe I'm trying to get
better at it
kind of stuck at it but you know
whatever
hit the Subscribe button because you can
vote for bonehead of the week here on
YouTube if you're watching on YouTube on
our Channel you can vote every single
week under the Community tab that's the
tab where we can post things and we post
a poll every week for bone end of the
week you can also vote on Twitter if you
follow us at oh no that's Facebook sorry
there's Twitter at Tony Michaels Pond I
hit the wrong button
at Tony Michaels pod you can follow us
on Twitter you can vote every week and
you can watch bone net of the week every
Friday on Facebook there you go
you can watch it live at the Tony
Michaels on Facebook you can also watch
it on Twitch it's free to follow us on
Twitch don't forget if you have your
Amazon Prime account link to your Twitch
account you gotta go back to twitch.tv
Tony Michaels and resubscribe with that
Amazon Prime account and if you have an
Amazon Prime account and have it linked
it to your Twitch account you should do
that as well it gives us two dollars and
it's like two dollars in the end two
dollars seven cents something like that
is what Amazon gives us if you link your
Amazon account to your Twitch account
and give us that one free subscription
you get through Amazon gaming
it's kind of cool it doesn't cost you
any extra money
and it gives us a few bucks of Amazon's
money every month so go to the Tony
michaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com it's the fourth link down
that says link Amazon and Twitch account
also why you're at the Tony michaels.com
check out my patreon page patreon.com
the Tony Michaels will be doing a rant
and then ask me anything this weekend
that's right I'll be doing a rant and
ask me anything this weekend I'm going
to talk about something special I want
to do something special on my patreon
and this weekend we're going to talk
about it in the chat
when we're on the ramp this weekend
so don't forget to go to the
tonymichaels.com check out the patreon
page and join us this weekend on the
conversation of the special thing I want
to develop in the patreon it's gonna do
with engaging in our democracy I want to
do like a workshop thing it's kind of
cool kind of cool and someone is a few
people gave me idea and I kind of ran
with it and I think we're gonna do it
we're gonna do democracy style Workshop
things so come this weekend go to the
Tony michaels.com click on the patreon
link or go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels come join us this weekend
and find out what we're gonna do over
there on patreon over the next 18 months
get ready for this election don't go
anywhere we'll be right back right after
this
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
I've always wanted to learn a new
language but whenever I try it never
sticks so when Babel made a MAG Edition
I knew I had to give it a try Babel Maga
Edition makes it really easy to learn
and there's lots of lessons to choose
from like subtly racist to full-blown
white supremacists the first lesson
began with learning simple phrases and
soon I was putting those words and
phrases into a conversation each lesson
takes about 10 to 15 minutes to complete
and they're all really different which
keeps things interesting the app is
really smart it actually keeps track of
the word that I'm struggling with I
chose Babel mag Edition because it's
created by smart white people like me
and now I can't wait to explore meet new
friends and use my new Mega skills with
my in-laws all lives matter
[Music]
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
end of the week
[Music]
Gabe Sanchez gonna join us at the top of
the hour
[Music]
of the week
is that your favorite segment it's one
of mine I love bonehead
shake it up you know we get to make fun
of them mock them but that's what we do
anyways so you know what the hell's the
difference what the hell's the
difference
so um I want to show you a few um Clips
here of course but you know what
I'm gonna go off script here why don't
we do why don't we do and shoot the [__]
here if you got a question since I know
I know you guys got a lot of questions
probably about like the um
the the trials and all that kind of
stuff like what's gonna happen with the
indictments and all that and I'm not a
lawyer I'm just trying to use my common
sense to look at this stuff so why not
if you want I have put a few questions
in the chat there we're gonna do two
things I'm gonna show you some clips
and we're going to
um show you some color I'm going to show
you some Clues and we're gonna answer
some questions so
um
Allison asked this is a good question
because I am Marjorie Taylor green Clips
I want to show you now Marjorie Taylor
green almost always ends up on the bone
of the weeple and she always wins so
this week because she certainly could
have been on this week and I'm sure she
certainly could be on next week's bone
of the week uh and you know verse
showing Hunter Biden porn but I decided
not to put her on the pole because she
would [__] win
because she is the biggest bonehead ever
I'm actually thinking that we should ban
her from the bonehead of the week list
Allison here is talking about the exact
reason why she should have been on the
bonehead of the week poll this week by
showing porn in a congressional hearing
now the problem is is she can't be
arrested for showing these pictures
inside of the hearing I know I know a
lot of people think it's felonies a lot
of people want to act like again folks
stop with the [__] that isn't going to
happen stop it it's it's it's it's not
only is it annoying as [__]
but it gets people's hopes up when you
start saying this [__]
they are not going to charge Marjorie
Taylor green for felonies for showing
that picture during a congressional
hearing the problem is
that people in Georgia Vote for This
vile piece of trash
and when you put people like that
[__] [__] that's right I'll use the
word [__]
because that's what she is when you put
people like that as as your member of
Congress you get these types of trashy
outcomes
that's what happens
I don't I do not make this [__] up I
didn't force her
to print off pictures of Hunter Biden's
porn and hold it up during a
congressional hearing but get over the
fact she's not gonna be charged
she's not
and even if she is charged it's not
because she held it up in a hearing it's
because of the emails we talked about
this yesterday with Fred Wellman it is
more likely that she'll get charged for
Distributing revenge porn inside of her
her fundraising emails than she will
holding it up in a congressional hearing
and she even used the was careful to use
the words that this is evidence
which should the rules change Maybe
but if you think the rules are going to
change with these [__] moglodytes in
charge of the house then you're [__]
dreaming and the only way to change that
is to engage in your democracy not hope
that they're going to charge you with a
felony and she won't be a congresswoman
anymore stop relying on someone else to
do our job
okay and then that's what I'm trying to
say every day stop
getting so excited about someone else
doing the job that you have to I know
what I know democracy is difficult
liberalism is the foundation of strength
it takes a lot of will
it takes a long time it takes a lot of
hard work to deliver Liberty to to a
nation
it really does it takes a lot of work
it's not easy
authoritarianism is easy you just choose
one person and they get to decide
everything that's [__] easy
liberalism is hard it really is we see
it right in front of us
the liberty for that that District in
Georgia to vote for that vile piece of
trash Marjorie Taylor green and put her
in office it causes a lot of issues
like holding up revenge porn in a
congressional hearing
again I talked about this yesterday
friend Milt Wellman the one reason why
is because
she's not a serious person and she does
not attract serious [__]
people to her staff
nor Will's will she so I don't know
Allison uh if I can tell you that she
will be arrested for Revenge foreign I
actually think she will not be
arrested for revenge porn that's just my
feeling on it and not that I don't think
she should be I just don't think she
will be
I mean if this is the case then we
should have been arresting members of
Congress for trying to overthrow our
government years ago
just hang on to your hat I think there's
more uh charges coming from Marjorie
Taylor green I know something about pipe
bombs or something I don't know let's
watch let's watch a clip with the pipe
bomb I mean Marjorie Taylor green here
um she's talking about of course the
doj's two-tier justice system but let's
hear she's on she's on here with uh
slobber slobbery mctrumpster here
let's let's listen to what she said on
Fox Business why is Marjorie Taylor
green anywhere near the business Channel
I don't know uh this is going to come to
nothing I mean we've had all these
lawyers on the last two nights nobody
can figure out what the charges are this
uh prosecutor Jack Smith has a terrible
record he lost ain't nothing with the
Supreme Court he's had problems with
other cases Marjorie Taylor green is
there a way to put some heat on this guy
okay so
hey hey [__] hey dip [__] hey kavogo
I love you Affair you need to stop
drinking and look at the charges he
asked what the charges were there's 37
charges
with the Espionage Act in Florida that's
those charges are those the charges
you're talking about because
those are certainly Federal felonies
that he's charged with but let's let's
see how Marjorie Taylor green wants to
undermine the justice system in a way
that isn't possible let's hear it
well I would like to do that my plan and
I've had it all along is to defund Jack
Smith's special counsel uh we can do
that through the Holmen rule uh oh she's
had it all along so here's the thing
Marjorie Taylor green is telling us all
along her plan was to make sure that
Trump never seen Justice
before the evidence before before the
special counsel did any kind of
investigating before Trump opened his
big [__] mouth and let all the
[__] evidence out of the bag
we have [__] break yeah again when
you hear them tell the truth you need to
believe them she's saying all along the
whole time I've never wanted a special
counselor because I don't want Trump to
be held accountable because if he is
then he'll go to prison that's bad so we
got to use the Appropriations
process to get rid of the special
counsel which actually I don't know
Marge knows that I don't know if she
knows this or not that's not a thing
that's not a thing that's actually why
you have a special prosecutor
so you can't [__] with it I don't know
if she knows that but let's keep going
um and work that through the
Appropriations process I think it's
extremely important for us to do I
believe in firing people Larry and I
think Jack Smith needs to be fired uh
for bringing we don't even know the
charges he's bringing against President
Trump yes we do we know the charges that
he's bringing we know them there's 37 of
them so far you don't know the charges
in the January 6 case
I mean or do you there's only a certain
array of charges cons seditious
conspiracy obstructing official
proceeding wire fraud mail fraud or
might be racketeering charges in that
case I mean there there are several I
mean
the evidence is there so you would
presume that these are the certain
amount of charges that you could charge
him with and I bet we're gonna find out
what he's going to indict him on when he
um what's it called indicts him
Christ a bunch of [__] Rubes what a
bunch of jokes what a joke Kudlow green
What charges are they charging him with
it's like there's an indictment that I
can read but I won't read it here's
another really bone-headed clip since
she's not on bonehead let's listen to
another bone-headed thing that she said
on kudlow's show today Mr Ziegler he was
a great witness and and you know for
everyone watching at home Mr Ziegler is
a Democrat Mr Ziegler is a gay man
married to another man
hell boy they really like they really
really really like
they really like the lgbtq community
when it suits them you notice that when
it suits them they're really all for it
right all right he's a you should be
nice to him he's a gay man who's married
to another man
uh okay cool right that still doesn't
make him a fake elector I mean excuse me
a fake whistleblower I get confused they
got fake electors they got fake
whistleblowers all these [__] things
are fake they're all [__] fake I mean
even even their that grassly releasing
that the the the 10 23 yesterday fake
it's all fake it's [__] [__]
but you know these two are fake here he
says that he has received a lot of
backlash for members of his own party
and have has been attacked uh his
husband as well which is so wrong oh
it's so wrong to attack
gay people is that really what she's
saying is that what she's saying
is that it's
dead it's wrong to it she attacks the
lgbtq community and gay people on a
daily every [__] day she's attacking
those people and she's encouraging
people to attack them and and [__]
threaten their lives and everything else
what the [__] are you talking about
oh it's so it's so wrong that he was
attacked attacked he's a liar what do
you want he's a fake whistleblower what
do you want he's playing the Trump game
what do you want from us we're not no
one said he's attacking him because of
his sexuality or his sexual orientation
what are you talking about
that has nothing to do with it or his
political affiliation we noticed
yesterday political affiliation doesn't
mean [__] anymore with RFK Jr going to
the house weaponization committee Jim
Jordan's scam ass fake committee they
got fake committees they got fake
[__] whistleblowers they got fake
[__] electors
it's all [__] fraud if you want to
know the honest truth but it's Marjorie
Taylor green what more would you expect
from her so there you go there's your
Marjorie
[Music]
um
bonehead what other questions do we get
let's see if we can um get some more
questions in here
I I I I know I was supposed to do clips
and thing but I went off on a tangent
what do you want for me
oh there's some comments in here but you
guys are
oh you guys are you guys are the best
audience in the world I love to pull up
some of these comments but I think
YouTube might uh
I think YouTube might ban me if I pull
up some of your guys's comments here
keep them coming though keep them coming
I'm not scared
um
don't want to pull them up on screen you
guys are wild I like it I like it I like
it okay let's move on to another clip
here if you guys got questions throw
them in the channel see if I can grab a
question or two and answer them uh and
just I grabbed that one uh with Marjorie
Taylor green because it was where I was
going anyways it's almost like Allison I
think it was Allison's question knew
exactly where I was going
[Music]
um
with this
um here's a weird ass clip actually you
know what I'm gonna save this one I'm
Gonna Save this clean
damn it I can't decide if I want to show
this one now or show it during bonehead
and rent says here Will trump evade jail
by fleeing the country no
I I don't think he could go anywhere
there's nowhere he can go
right
I mean think think about think about how
how much he loves being around his
toothless sheep right his brainless
delusional toothless redneck sheep right
I mean that's the only thing he got he's
got left
no one else likes him right no one else
will line up in a hay field to come see
him besides these [__]
so I don't think he's leaving the
country because he isn't going to get
any kind of Welcome like that anywhere
else
and it's that's his best drug he's got
going you know you know what I mean you
know what I mean uh let's see there's
another question in here I'm trying to
decide if I want to show this clip of
Jim Comer and Ted Cruz
because they may or may not make
appearances
um
someone um Margie's on Facebook says
Tony do you get the money from the Stars
bought here during your program if you
put stars in there eventually I will get
them yes
but I don't think there's enough for me
to even monetize it because Facebook
doesn't pay hardly anything for those
but keep if keep them coming if that's
how you want to support the best way
honestly let me show you something the
best way to support the show
um if if what you want is to give
monetaries and I know I don't mean to go
off too much of a tangent here but if
you want to get monetary support because
a lot of people ask me about this a lot
of people ask about the the twitch page
the patreon
um what's the difference where do I get
the most support the most support if you
want to give money like if you just want
to give money and you don't really want
anything other than to support the show
because a lot of people that's what they
want the best way is to go to the uh my
website the Tony michaels.com go down
and just uh go to the tip jar here see
the tip jar right here right here the
tip jar you click on that and you can
give whatever amount you want or you can
give 5 10 20 or whatever amount doesn't
matter you can type it in there and you
can just give a tip jar right there
right there on the website that's the
best way because they take the least
amount
if that makes sense now I'm I don't want
to tell you how to give because it's
your choice your choice if you want to
go to the merch store and buy some merch
you can go right down here to the merch
stores right here
or if you want to buy a [__] em hat the
[__] them answer right here if you want
to buy some Gabe Sanchez Merchant
support Gabe Gabe gets all the money
from his merch store so it's right there
we're transparent about this this is how
we make our living
now now it is it's how and how I make my
living now so I need support if you can
give it but if you can't give it the
best if you can't get monetary support
the best support you can give is to come
watch it every single day uh download
the audio version that's a great way to
give us support download it on Apple
Spotify Google
and in every day if you can download it
it's free to download doesn't cost you
anything to download it so if you can't
give monetary support there's other ways
to give support you can share the link
every single day if you if you want to
give the star thing on Facebook
eventually I'll get it because it builds
up in an account and then eventually if
I monetize when I monetize with Facebook
I'll get the credit but there's just
they don't pay enough for the stars for
me to really there's not a lot there but
I'll get it I'll get it eventually so if
you're given Stars yes I will get it
eventually but there's just not enough
there yet to get those but I will I will
so however you want to support the show
is completely up to you another another
way to support the show really easy is
to subscribe and like every single
episode watch every single episode send
the link to every single episode like on
social media if you download it on Apple
and you like the audio version there's
been some people on threads post the
link to the to the recent episode on
threads so you'll do that on social
media all those things are support
whether it's money or not so yes if
you're giving stars on Facebook I will
get those I will get those eventually
um because they hold in an account so
if that's the way that you like to
support the show more power to you I
like it keep going obviously
because that is how we get paid here
because we don't have any corporate big
corporate sponsors because
they don't really like how I say things
yet yet if we get a big enough audience
uh there'll there'll be people in droves
coming to trying to I have to turn away
people probably like no I don't like
your product
I don't think the audience and we'll
probably get you involved in that
process when we start getting sponsors
like do you guys like this product do
you like it they want to sponsor us
let's do that
how can I send bottles of Jaeger that I
can't drink
oh boy
that's tempting Peter and Peter from
Facebook wants to know if he can send me
some bottles of Jager that's very
tempting everyone knows here at the show
that I like Jagermeister most people
don't but I do
let's see do we have any more questions
um
now let's see let's see if we have
another question here
um so looting here on Twitch says our
patreon parties for five bucks payments
as well are only for the upper level so
the patreon the patreon is one big
family and there's different tiers but a
lot most of folks over on patreon and
the people in the chat that are patreon
members of patreon will tell you in the
chat that we're not we're not picky and
choosy about what what tier you're in we
want everyone to be included
um and most most the stuff we do
everyone is [__] sometimes I make them
public so that people can come in that
aren't patrons
um because the patreon is about not just
about the extra content it is because we
do that like we had a we had a what was
it like an hour and a half I think we
docked on Sunday
we need a rant and ask me anything on on
Sunday on the patreon page and uh it was
a great there was about 30 35 folks
people there and we're just talking back
and forth we're having a conversation
with each other it was really good and
if you want to see it if you want to
join the patreon if you do if you join
the five dollars then then you can go
watch that that link and you can watch
all the last ask me any things and
patreon and all that stuff you can go in
and see all that stuff for the five
dollars
um because we're not we I don't I don't
try to because most people are there to
support me and the show and keep us
going and keep our pockets full so we
can keep doing this
um so it's more it's more about just
creating Community outside the show and
doing different stuff outside the show
but we aren't this weekend I will have a
I will have an event this weekend it'll
be a like a rant like a a weekend rant
I'm not sure if I'll do it tomorrow or
Sunday I just don't know what my
schedule is going to look like but we're
going to talk about something new that I
want to do a couple times a month
and it's more like a workshop type thing
I want to do like a workshop where it's
like a democracy Workshop or maybe we
bring on guests and we do we do certain
types of training on how you can
actually engage I know uh when I uh here
on the show I I do 50 000 foot
narratives right 50 000 foot narratives
and more and more people uh send me
messages about how to get involved or
that they're getting involved and it's
really exciting because that's that's
what I'm wanting you to do is go out and
get involved register people or make
phone calls or do postcards or help
campaigns or just talk to the people
that are in your community and your
family so that's what I want you to do
now again the show here is for 50 000
foot narratives and commentary
um but I think we're going to do more
detailed workshops there on patreon so
come this weekend check it out
um on the patreon and see what we're
going to be working on over on the
workshops because I want the the patreon
members to also have say and see what
they think and what what they want to
see out of some sort of Workshop that we
would do I'm like it's like a democracy
Workshop type thing so I think it's
going to be pretty cool I think it'll be
really good over the next several months
let's see what other questions do we
have here
yeah okay let's see I'm reading some
questions but and and
Bridget on YouTube says well boycott
binder ever be available I doubt it it
is just a it is kind of funny though
right that's a great one and Gabe
Sanchez did that video like two years
ago or something crazy it was a long
time ago that he did a boycott binder
and it still applies like it will still
apply to them it keeps going
it keeps going
it keeps going and going and going and
and going it's it's like the pardon one
the pardon blanket oh that one's that
one's gonna be fresh for a long time
right
it really is it really is okay let's go
back and see if we can find another clip
I think there was another clip I wanted
to show you before we go to bonehead uh
we got about five ten minutes
before Gabe Sanchez gets here Sanchez oh
yes
oh yes there's a clip I want to show you
this has nothing to do with politics by
the way but it's funny as hell you know
it's hotter than [__] climate change
it's happening all over the world
Republicans are turning a blind eye they
can't even see it when they see it but I
you know the good news is the good news
is there are silver linings to climate
change uh this guy has found a way to
cook let's listen
here in Vegas when it's 115 degrees you
don't even have to wait to get home from
the store to cook your hot dogs
oh man we should have put the Buns on
the roof to toast them
[Laughter]
on the car antenna
um oh man
wish it's [__] hot isn't it it's hot
when you can cook the hot dogs on the
way home you know Grill the hot dogs in
the Sun
I'm sure it would work actually I know
it would work so years ago
um when I was an over the road sales
version you know you know I've told you
before that I listen right wing Taco
radio but every once in a while I'd have
to go with someone like we'd have
ride-alongs and stuff and we'd partner
up and stuff and uh there was this one
guy
he would always he'd always bring his
lunch in the summer and it'd be hotter
than hell I mean it's just hotter than
[__] here in like July and August in
Missouri especially in the back window
of a car right especially if the car is
going to sit out in the driveway for
like two hours so what he would do is he
would get his lunch out in the morning
and he'd he'd throw his lunch in the
back window of his car it was like a I
don't know it's like an Impala or
something right like a four-door Impala
and he'd throw the he'd throw his lunch
I remember most times he's like chicken
breast or some [__] like that so he'd
throw his lunch in the back window of
the car that way by lunch time you know
we'd let the car sit two or three times
in the sun all day yeah
he would uh by the time he got to
lunchtime his lunch would be warm his
lunch would be warm you didn't have to
use a microwave or anything so but yeah
it's so goddamn hot you can cook hot
dogs on your car and denim
I bet it would work I bet you could
toast the Buns on the roof too that's um
no doubt no doubt okay let's see what
other clip do I got oh you remember the
Jason Aldean story right I did a thing
on it it was it yesterday and I talked
about Jason Aldean or Wednesday
Wednesday or yesterday I remember I
couldn't ignore it anymore I listened to
the song It's a [__] song objectively
it's garbage and there's a lot of people
online debating whether Jason Aldean is
actually an artist or not because he
didn't actually write the song which is
kind of garbage because there's a lot of
artists out there that don't write their
own songs and there's a lot of famous
people who write songs who do release
songs that are written by other people
it's a it's a it's a typical thing in
the music industry but Jason Aldean is
not a small town guy he's not from a
[__] small town he's just not and he
lives in Nashville
which I don't know if you know anything
about Nashville but just because it's in
Tennessee doesn't make it a small town
it's actually not
a small town
but here is uh if you need to know
anything more okay if you need to know
anything more about Jason Aldean oh I'm
not making excuses for that [__]
don't get me wrong if you could go
listen to my rant the other day [__]
that guy [__] Jason Aldean [__] him
and and the the video in that song the
lyrics and and and then the whining and
the crying oh that's not what it's about
[__] get the [__] out of here you
know exactly what it's about you pieces
of trash and if you need any other
evidence okay any other evidence of why
why why you should not [__] listen to
that song or give a [__] not two [__]
about Jason Aldean because to be quite
honest I wasn't as hard on the left that
I should have been the other day when I
was doing my rant about the song
honestly if the left would have just did
what they should have done and ignored
that [__] Jason Aldean is
irrelevant they [__] wrote that song
for ye eat boys white in cell ye eat
boys who [__] drive big ass trucks to
compensate for their little dicks that's
who they wrote that song for they know
who they wrote it for they know who
Jason Aldean's audience is it's a bunch
of [__] geek geek boys
and sell white boys who have to over
compensate for their tiny little dicks
that's who it is 100 percent
but if there's any other evidence that
you need
to know why Jason Aldean shouldn't even
be there in the relevance of social
media it's this right here this is a
picture of Jason Aldean and his [__]
wife that's right I called her a [__]
wife because that's what she is
look at this look who's smooching on her
what a [__] cuck
Jason Aldean is a God damn cuck and he's
a trump cuck makes it even worse what
more evidence do you need besides this
picture right here to to not give a [__]
about what Jason Aldean says or sings
[__] him [__] his wife and [__] Trump
[__] him
I don't even know if I'm ever gonna
bring up him again just because of that
picture so not for me it's enough for me
I do want to move on to something else I
thought I had a [__] clip oh yes I do
I do speaking of a great song speaking
of Jason Aldean I said I was never going
to bring him up again but oh God damn
here's here's a new someone everyone is
recording his song and here's a version
of Jason Aldean song let's take a listen
hey It's Mia Dean the artist
I uh
I'm gonna level with you here I don't
agree with the politics of Jason Aldean
in any way but I got a call from the
record execs this morning they said that
uh he's trending really well and if we
want to see some higher Impressions and
some uh some retweets stuff like that we
really ought to do a cover of a Jason
Aldean song and I thought well
Impressions is what I care about most so
let's do this you know what I mean so uh
please share it away this is Jason
Aldean's new hit uh it's called some
downtown
yeah
we got no protests or civil unrest never
took a goddamn cover test and we can all
read but we don't do it driving trucks
valued higher than a new Corvette yeah
we all wear boots and we love to shoot
and we root for the cops to stop people
like you this is a sun downtown
oh baby it's a Sundown
better never let the sun go down
[Music]
that's true that I am ignorant on most
of this a couple folks for some reason
called me a bigot let us win a lot yeah
I'm singing loud even though I didn't
like the [__] I'm singing about I just
read the words and say yeah that one was
good as long as it applies again
[Music]
oh baby it's a sundown time but I never
let the sun go down
laughs
that's a
that's Jason Aldean
so obviously if you don't know that
satire he's obviously making fun of
Jason Aldean and basically what he's
doing is writing the lyrics the way that
they should have been written and the
way that they they should
um the chance asking who this is I'll
show you the handle here uh I deemed the
uh the operaist dean the artist here's
the uh here's the account here
let's see did I follow it yeah I'm gonna
follow right now here's the um
here's their pronouns are they them
everyone has pronouns what are yours
cast iron pansexual white trash so go go
check out
um this artist on Twitter let's see uh
and you can go here I'll give the um
copy I'll give the uh here I'll give the
moderators the the link base can you
give this and pass this along there
here's the here's the um the the website
to their links
that's a great song I love it a lot of
people are confused about whether it's
parody or not it it is parody it is
satire so uh you're welcome and if
you'll pass it along to the to the
moderators
um that'd be great and where they can
get it in the chance I'd throw it in the
chat but sometimes I mess it up the
monteres are much better at me putting
links in the chat
oh did you hear did you hear that Greg
Abbott is a vile piece of fascist [__]
oh my God it's almost like I've said
this from the beginning that he was
going to get people killed at the border
and apparently the cruelty is the point
the cruelty is the point a mother and
her two children died trying to cross
the river they were trying to coerce uh
the mother and children a certain plot
spot they pull them they finally they
finally pulled the the dying children
and mother out I mean these are yeah
Greg Abbott's pro-life okay he was gonna
wait until they were almost dead to pull
them from the water
hey you you think I'm being insensitive
about this look the cruelty is the point
I've been telling you this from the
beginning that these people are gonna
get their fascism is gonna get people
[__] killed
and it's killing women and children
trying to cross the border to come here
to have a better life
that's all they want they want to come
to America to have a chance at a better
life
and Greg Abbott is trying to kill them
as they're crossing the border
kill them
I mean I've heard I've heard Trump
supporters
that I know people I know personally say
well they should just shoot those people
when they cross the border shoot them
shoot them and kill them like snipers
I'm like what the [__] you're talking
about women and children so what
the cruelty is the point folks
that's what they're going for that's why
they did family separation that's what
they wanted you to think they were gonna
they wanted migrants to think that the
government would kidnap their children
and separate them to where they never
see them again the cruelty is the point
to try to get them to not come to
America and be hard-working
productive members of our country and
our nation like we've always done in
this country and we should continue well
we've had Parts in our history where we
didn't that really offends white people
doesn't it
oh man they're pissed off so much so
that Florida and Rhonda Santos are like
slavery well slavery was good they had
like places to sleep on the ground and
stuff I mean they kind of fed them it
kind of had a I mean some slaves liked
it probably that's literally what
Florida wants to teach children now
they want to change the slavery
curriculum so it doesn't offend white
people well get the [__] out of here if
you are offended and you feel guilty
about the truth of America and the truth
about what white people did to black
people in America you're a [__]
racist I'm sorry that's just the cold
hard facts if you're in any way guilt
feel guilty or you do you feel you know
offended about the actual history what
actually happened in this country what
white people did to black people and
you're offended or you feel guilty about
it you are a [__] racist
you're a [__] racist
if you think then you're you're just a
[__] racist right Gabe
right
right hey he's trying to give me one
second I already pulled him up he can't
hear me uh poor guy he's sitting there
and he's just blind I could say anything
and everything I could tell him to agree
with me on anything tell him to shake
shake shake your head yes shake your
head yes yeah yeah he has no he's like
no I'm not gonna do it you're baiting me
he knows I'm baiting him
uh I'll take him off the screen for now
until he figures that oh no oh now
you're good now you're good now you're
fine yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah now I'm
good I was saying you're a racist I'm
saying not you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah racist I was ganged racists right
well what I was saying is is that in
Florida did you hear that they they want
to change how they're teaching slavery
like no slaves liked being slaves and so
they wanted yeah yeah right because they
don't want white people to feel guilty
I'm like look if you're a white person
you feel guilty or you're offended by
the actual history of what how the
Despicable things that white people did
the black people in this country if that
offends you or makes you feel guilty
you're a [__] racist yeah like maybe
maybe it says more about you instead of
saying hey look that was a terrible time
in our history of our country we should
never do that again we should learn from
our mistakes right you're definitely
going down
exactly and so the idea that somebody's
like it's like maybe you're getting
offended because it hits a little too
close to home right exactly maybe you
want it to be that way right because you
feel like you're better than everyone
else I I did a video on Tick Tock years
ago because people are so mad man when I
first started my Tick Tock account
people would get so [__] mad when I
would call Republicans Nazis like even
people after like they're like Tony
Jesus Christ you can't call white people
Nazis I'm like look
if you're offended then I call white
people Nazis I'm talking to you right
like you're the one that I'm talking to
well it's also like when you know when
people say like all men are trash right
and it's like or or like uh
like acap right like all cops are are
bastards or bads depending on what
version you know right right whichever
one you want to go with right right but
again it's one of those things where
where people were like oh my God and
it's like okay one are you any of those
things are you are you in that group if
so you know I think that you can come to
the realization and say yeah you know
what there are some bad people in the
bench the bunch and they're giving us
all a bad name and maybe we should try
to reassess and maybe reform what we're
doing here right instead of say whoa
whoa whoa and then go after the person
that said it it's like a good idea the
good idea is to take the bad apples in
the bunch and put them on the compost
pile for good yeah take those bad apples
out put them on the compost pile and
then you got you still got a basket of
good apps yes right oh man I made a I'm
in a tick tock uh in 2020 that was
making fun of like the Bad Apple
argument right right and about how cops
were protected you know police unions
and their you know uh the ability to The
Good the good cops protect the bad guys
exactly there's the blue wall right
there's all these different ways the way
that you can skirt by going from one
jurisdiction and you travel to another
one you're like yep new cop like new
phone who this new cop who it is right
like that's what it is and people got
offended and I was like I'm just I'm
literally just laying it out
I'm just telling you what it is and the
beauty of it was there was a loop of you
know covering the police Union qualified
immunity and and everything being able
to get a job somewhere else and having
the conversation again and again and
again without somebody actually getting
the the consequences saying okay look
you should not be a cop you are not a
cop you can't be a cop anywhere
um which is a broken system and how
because every
there's no there's no uh unified or
Central database for you to track these
different police and their things you
have to call out and it's an effort well
the other thing too is they should be
uninsurable because I don't know how
people know this but but literally uh
like police departments have to buy
insurance policies on each one of their
officers right like they own an
insurance policy that way if they ever
get sued they but but they should become
uninsurable which means if they're
uninsurable no one can hire them as a
justice of the peace that you can't be a
police officer so you can't be one
because you're uninsurable are you
saying are you saying that like there's
like a one and done like you have it
once and you lose it or you don't I mean
I I again if you're looking to me for
[__] policy points you're in the
wrong place right I'm just saying
there's an idea out there the idea is is
one of the ways to fix the qualifying
immunity thing is that they would be
insured so you would still leave
qualified immunity right but you would
have this level of of insurability and
it would be a separate board and a
separate entity an entire separate
agency that would determine whether
someone is insurable even someone who
has mental health problems that is a
police officer if there's a certain
level of mental health or they've had a
certain they can be uninsurable for a
time being and you can't be an officer
if you're not if you can't be insured
right like that should be the case I
mean our contractors are licensed bonded
and insured so why shouldn't and if you
and if you do a lot of bad [__] when
you're a contractor no one will bond you
ensure you are licensed you right so it
should be the same thing with officers I
mean it makes sense you know you should
you shouldn't have this you know the
qualified immunity you shouldn't have
the ability to just skirt around the law
right like you aren't above it you're
right you're a private citizen who's
been given the privilege right to have
this job and if you abuse it yeah then
you lose it you should be able to be
insured speaking of people aren't
qualified for anything here's Mike Pence
this picture is hilarious dude there is
not one full head of hair in this
[__] Crowd Oh my God holy [__] this
is the former Vice President of the
United States and it looks like he's in
the uh I don't know is this the 4-H
building he's in wherever something Lake
I don't know
why hold on
Lake
Lake grain crange Grange I don't know I
don't know anyways I'll find it this
seems like a you know an old 4-H club or
something that he's in that these people
are sitting in these yeah metal folding
chairs these rusted metal folding chairs
but not one not one dude in this entire
crowd has a full head of hair I'm like
holy dog [__] like and there's probably
what maybe 40 50 at best this is a
former Vice President of the United
States he's really this dude collects
more flies on his head than he can you
know in the room with these people but
you know on did you find anything about
it surprising it's not even on the
Internet it's so old and so so obscure
this thing isn't even on the internet I
think it's
yeah I don't know I'm looking for I
found a Davis Lake Grange but I'm trying
to figure out what it says I have no
idea it says dub mikwas no Wick wasp
Lake range I think is what it says here
let me let me let me send you this let
me send you this the link to this yeah
yeah it's quick because it was Ron that
had it here he said Pence with another
diverse event yeah really diverse so let
me let me copy this uh this and put it
in the private chat and then you can you
can track down and see if you can find
the uh you can zoom in on it better than
I can here on the show dance there it is
but when I do that you know it [__] up
my [__] I know I got my [__] here it
[__] everything [__] up my entire
Command Center and all the staff here
gets really mad when it happens all the
people we got 20 people that sit here
and they do the thing that way when I
call go to the go to the
hold on I'll just send you the link
uh
okay so this is a comment here in the uh
in the chat of this that's what Gabe
Sanchez does when he finds a good tweet
he's he's down in the comments like a
[__] but the Sue B here has
oh [__] oh God damn
there's a mingler In The Crowd Oh man oh
that's hilarious
um yeah I can't find I don't know where
he is uh there's no context to no but
that's again it's because it's so
obscure yeah that even the internet's
like I don't know what the hell you're
talking about honestly like I was like I
was hoping that that Google would be
like oh did you mean this and then I'm
like oh yeah that's what I meant
um but I'm looking I'm looking here and
I've only got they can't even give you a
suggestion maybe mate let me see where
this is nope that's India never mind
I don't know like it could be he could
be in India I mean maybe maybe he flew
those people over there yeah the closest
thing I found was a Davis Lake Grange
let's see what state this is in
Davis like Grange
California I gotta go to the Facebook no
this isn't there's no reason to be out
on the west coast no no he's that's not
it that's not it speaking of people
running for president and I'm being
right about it I don't know if you saw
this this morning this was a Grandpa's
little uh no this was last night I'm
sorry this was last night when he was
sitting on the [__]
and he's he's how are you a solid minus
one percent
like she went down one percent or is she
a negative no is Asa he's calling he's
he's making fun it's Assa Hutchinson I
call him NASA but solid minus one
percent that's what I'm saying like is
it negative one percent or it's like I
If you're looking for logic in these
[__] these these absolute lunatic
post I don't know what I'm sure
somebody's like oh minus one percent 44
Ada Ada is one I'm sure or whatever the
hell it is meganomics well he says the
deck ramaswami is now beating the
sanctimonious I called it I called it I
told you this would happen months ago I
said it when I first heard the
[__] that that's what he was
that's exactly the reason why he's in
the race Christy dead as his stomach as
his stomach band I think he's making fun
of him because Chris Christie apparently
had like a lap band installed and then
he had it uninstalled is that what he's
saying is that what he's saying he's
talking about hudges in a mine uh solid
minus one percent I'm up 44 pints
make America great again I just want to
know like every night every night he
goes to bed and he's like um
I know I know it I'm gonna do so well
and then he like dreams about a poll and
then he wakes up in the middle of the
night as he goes to take his like
Adderall ridden [__] and he's like ah 44
points and someone's like what the [__]
are you talking about like who was it
yesterday that was um oh it was Fox News
and it was like 71 to 17 now 14 I think
yeah it was like 57 difference they're
like RFK Juniors really coming up
like all right yeah okay okay
wait wait tell wait tell those uh those
lunatic answers that he gave in the
house weaponization committee wait till
they hit the polls yeah get the [__] out
of here with this nonsense so here's
what I said I said I'm just gonna leave
this here because I tweeted this on July
15th I said you're gonna watch Trump
claim in the coming months
this is the only candidate who can beat
him
he may be the only person Trump actually
debates Vivek ramaswamy is an election
op I just want to know who convinced him
to be that op that you can probably
guess and I was referring to
Vivek here in a clip that Republican
accountability posted of vivec on Blaze
TV
so if you doubt me I would advise
against it because he's already saying
it out loud what I told you he would be
saying I told you this I don't have like
an inside scoop I don't text Donald
Trump on a daily basis like every other
week but um but but I knew he I knew he
was going to do this with the bevec from
the first time I heard I think I told
you like the first time because he came
into one of those Twitter spaces and he
spoke yeah yeah and I asked him the
question right and I said
is anyone and I mean I I could have
followed up uh with is Donald Trump but
I said is anyone is any any person or
third party group paying you to run for
president and then he kind of like he's
like
I guess I think the way that he
responding what a dumb question he was
like oh well I mean I'm assuming this is
a serious question so I'll treat it as
serious so I have to laugh it up it's a
dead serious question like why who the
[__] are you and why the [__] are you
wanting and who's paying you to run
because what people might not know is
that Vivek Rama Swami did a little bit
of an Internet sweep uh before he
started running no [__] why is that is
it because he took money from someone
who the right wing may not like
whoa whoa wait he's well technically
technically cash his Sorrows checks God
damn it where's mine he he did in fact
uh uh
take money it was a grant so he was
given this money and it was George
soros's brother I think is what it was
oh but he had he paid someone on
Wikipedia to kill it and then it came
back and so wait so what you're saying
you're saying you're saying it was on
his Wikipedia bio yeah it's it's there
it's there now
brought it back yeah yeah and then and I
think it was like Slater someone was
like uh what's going on why did you pay
and then they followed up and then they
were like oh yeah he was paid so
Wikipedia put it back on there yeah yeah
hmm funny so he's scraping the internet
for all the [__] that he doesn't yeah he
tried to there are a couple other things
but that was the main one and also the
funny thing is like how much he's like
so against China but then is also the
beneficiary of China and using their
their supply chain Logistics that's the
reason why he is who he is anyways right
yeah yeah exactly well not only that but
also like Birthright citizenship oh that
thing oh yeah then you've also got you
know affirmative action he's such a
man's hat there but here's the thing
here's what I'll tell you Donald Trump
seems really excited about the Soros
back Republican candidate in the race
here that's all that's the narrative
that I think we should start pushing
yeah very excited Donald Trump also took
money from directly from Soros oh what
the [__] so he is the Soros candidate
yeah so I'm sure someone like you had to
take the money to understand how corrupt
he was it's it seems like it seems like
the Soros candidates are the Republicans
then
it would seem that way it would seem
that way yeah or or it's just that
George Soros has given money in various
forms to many different people on both
sides of the aisle Oh you mean it's just
not as it's not a conspiracy as well
yeah yeah it means that everyone's gone
I was hoping it was a conspiracy game
because then we would get our Soros
checks if they keep saying we're
supposed to get you know I know I know
I've been waiting man they I I was told
I was told by these people on the
internet that I was getting these checks
and I said what are you gonna do I'm
still waiting on it what are you gonna
do did you hear this morning that um
that Eileen Cannon she's gonna Save the
World by setting the trial for May of
next year right in the middle of the
election when he's gonna have delegates
and have the only the only reason he
needs for her to punt it even further
did you hear this oh my God yeah people
are getting excited about this this
morning here you can see her her order
huh the internet's like yeah he's gonna
go on trial in May I'm like no he's not
him jury trial set for May 20th 2024.
we'll see what happens I mean you know
uh uh Jack Smith wanted it in December
right right well you okay so so why do
you think Jack Smith won it in December
what what do you think his reasoning is
for December because he wanted as much
time as possible he could get that the
trial could actually happen and not be
further punted because right now we're
looking at a date where she was like oh
I split the difference
and it's I'll put it in May and we've
got an election in November right so it
is likely that we'll be pun in further
it'll get punted and rightly punted
again or they'll be like oh it's too
close to the election it's going to be
painting the results so that that's why
that's why I believe Jack Smith won it
in December because he wanted to he
wanted to go to try on this documents
case before a primary because Jack Smith
knows
I know he knows this that when Donald
Trump win starts to win delegates
he is going to have a real reason to go
to a federal judge and say hey you can't
put me on trial I am a nominee because
at this point he's not the nominee he's
not he's just presumed the front runner
but when he starts winning delegates he
will be the front runner he will have he
will have votes in his hand to go to a
federal judge and say see I am the front
runner there's nothing you can do about
it now and it's the case you will make
and honestly as much as I hate that
[__] pile of sludge it is a damn good
case it is a damn good case we should
not hurry down this road in this country
where we are Prosecuting people who are
viable nominees in their party now I
believe he's a criminal I believe he's a
piece of [__] I believe that the
Republican Party should have done their
duty to the country when he [__]
tried to overthrow our government and
they impeached him they should have
impeached him and 14th him then yeah
that was the time to impeach him in 14th
him to use the 14th Amendment to make
sure he never held public office again
but here's the thing you can't 14th him
if he's not convicted of anything you
can't everyone's like oh well she's just
14th and not allowing to run who who a
judge so you want authoritarian is it
you really want the justice system to
weaponize against a political candidate
because let me tell you something if
they do do it to him
when they gain power they will do it to
us
if you don't think these scumbags will I
mean they've literally said it I mean
Donald Trump has said it in his little
yes uh his whatever it's called um
uh
uh something 47 I'm blanking on the name
he hasn't in his videos he's like
playing 47 or initiative 47 or whatever
it is but he's literally said he's he's
come out and said the thing out loud I
mean so of so of other Republicans I
mean you were you're literally watching
it right now they said they were going
to come like if you if you try to do it
guys as in Republicans the Democrats if
you Democrats try to do anything if you
try to come after us we're going to make
sure that when we take over we're gonna
come after you and what do you see
happening right now I mean like it's a
big rake in the [__] face because
every person and everything that they've
shown has been a complete joke has been
a summarization of actual you know
information not real or the
whistleblowers or informants have gone
missing or they turn out to be Chinese
spies or you get random spoiler
candidates like RFK Jr trying to give
testimony about his Twitter account but
then it turned into some other [__]
hogwash but at the end of the day
their agenda 47. thank you Donna
Richards agenda 47. but what they're
going to do
is they're going to do exactly what
they're saying right now except on a
much larger scale and Donald Trump's
saying I'm gonna go after my enemies my
Nemesis it's like oh seems like you're
now weaponizing the political government
or the the government uh for your
political uh benefit you're going to go
after your enemies your uh
people who have who have stated they're
going to come after or those who have
um come after you I know in a in a legal
system right those who have gone after
him uh for the hush money for the
documents for the January 6 for uh
Fulton County for Eugene Carroll like
any number of things he's going to come
after those people because he has you
can bet your ass he has a grudge list
and he's gonna he's like that scene in
um Billy Madison where Steve Buscemi has
a list of people right and he crosses
off Billy Madison name because he says
he you know he apologize on the phone
but I I guarantee that Donald Trump
yeah I guarantee that Donald Trump has
the same type of list he's going to use
it if he and I don't think he will but
if in this crazy world he does take over
and get gets control again that will be
the thing that he does he will try to
use the government against his his
enemies well that's that's the fear that
I have here with this trial and and Lisa
here Lisa I know you're a viewer on a
regular cases and you're in all caps
here Garland should have had not drug
dragged his feet for a year here's the
thing
he didn't drag his feet that that's just
a a mischaracterization of of and and I
know that it's good to say these things
and I'm I'm begging you Lisa to not say
those things because that thing is not
the truth Merrick Garland struggled to
even get uh a senate to confirm him
um and get him in place so that he could
do this work and he's got a lot of other
work he's it's just not the Trump case
that Garland is responsible for he's
he's responsible for the entire
department of justice but here's what I
want to tell you about this if you think
that Merrick Garland drug his feet then
you believe that fonnie Willis drug her
feet and she did not there's no
indication that finding well is drug
revealed because we are literally Jack
Smith is going to indict on January 6 it
seems almost the exact same time that
Fannie Willis is going to indict on
January 6. and what it tells you is this
investigation took that long to get the
people who were in coordinating and
operating uh this this coup attempt the
people who were actually on the ground
who were [__] face timing themselves
and putting themselves on social media
being on being on recording being
violent and going into the capital that
was an easier and a faster timeline it's
a charge and prosecute those people that
it's much harder at this level to
prosecute these people so they haven't
drugged their feet yeah I promise you
they haven't drugged their feet and also
remember that like you know if if people
were to go too quick if they were to
rush into a oh these are the charges and
then we're gonna indict them on this you
better have a very strong case and you
better do your due diligence because if
you [__] up then that's it that's your
one shot and then people will be pissed
off that mayor Garland didn't do his job
and and was thorough right right and we
also have to remember that the people
that they're going after from the bottom
up like a thousand plus people from you
know Oath Keepers uh Patriot they've
been collecting evidence all along the
way each person is providing evidence to
benefit themselves in terms of what
their their time their serve the the
time that they have to service right
they're gonna say oh well I talked to
this person they said this well I talked
to this person they said this and they
keep going up because I mean it's it's
the it's the classic go after the main
head of the mob model right you go on
the outskirts to find the little guys
because they don't really care about
them they won't I mean like it's like
that scene in uh in the dark night where
they're like well how many of these
people are are there gonna get out uh
from from jail and like the little guys
won't be able to afford it the middle
guys maybe the top guys are going to be
fine they're going to get out but the
little guys are going to be the ones
that are flipping and the next ones are
gonna flip and the next ones are going
to flip and that's how they go in and
they tighten the circle and they say
okay great we've got you surrounded with
these direct contacts who said that you
did or said these things and we have it
uh you know under oath we have a
testimony or we have actual evidence or
proof or whatever it is and then you go
when you say boom now we've got you and
we'll go after you on these charges
because again if they go in
kind of half-assed or haphazardly or
whatever it might be then people who are
saying oh mayor Garland was dragging his
ass are going to be super pissed because
all that was our shot why'd you [__] it
up and it's like right you've got to be
you got it you gotta be prepared you got
to be prepared now Kim points out that
the January 6th committee referred
charges to the doj and we we covered
that live on the Mindless touch Network
when they did that and that is true but
they they don't they don't if they're
already investigating this issue they
don't need referrals nor do they need to
uh uh do a timeline based on that
referral from Congress and the January
6th select committee was more about the
American people knowing what happened
than to know what the to provide
evidence for the Department of Justice
to know what happened the Department of
Justice has way more sweeping power in
uh in the way of subpoena to get their
hands on evidence then what the January
6th select committee could ever dream of
um so now obviously there was an overlap
and some believe that maybe the January
6 Select Committee stalled the
investigation I don't know if that's
true I just think maybe they could have
coordinated a little better but that's
that's just the way of the world when
you're talking about the vision of
powers in this country we have
separation of power and the the January
6 select committee is in the Judea or
excuse me in the legislative branch and
the doj is in the executive branch so
there's a separation of powers there so
we can't uh it isn't our operation of
government to do that that's why
Congress has to refer those charges to
goj but just because they refer doesn't
mean the Department of Justice has to
take them or it doesn't mean the
Department of Justice hasn't already
walked in that way to get those reports
so I understand the frustration I
understand but also what I want you to
understand is the danger the danger of
being too reliant upon Merrick Garland
and Jack Smith
to save our democracy yeah that's the
that's the biggest danger I think that
we have we got to go to Bone end of the
week we really do we gotta go to bone in
the week stick around when we come back
we'll have bone of the week minus
Marjorie Tay that she would have won
don't you think she would she definitely
would I don't know this guy this was one
dude one this week he came out I don't
know
I think the hunter showing the hunter
[__] thing in the committee I think it
totally would have put her over the top
but I think I'm gonna ban her
permanently from the bonehead because
she just she's the super bonehead so she
wins every time so everyone stick around
we'll be right back bone of the week
when we come back
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
I now regret having a break
it gave a Gabe Sanchez
uh you're gonna see soon enough what I'm
talking about oh my God
some [__]
oh my god
oh we've reached Friday we're in the
second hour
it's time for bonehead of the week what
the [__] is this huh what the [__] is
this fellatio Blow The Shield blow baby
fellatio blow I even put I I made a
little oh it's on the other one well
I'll show when we're done with this oh
the the what what do you got there's oh
here I'll just I'll just upload it yeah
just upload it is sticking it you're
sticking to the old drive stick it in
the old bonehead sticking it stick it in
here so our software it has uh two we
got different Studios and I can switch
them that's going to a different Studio
it's like what the hell the different
that studios though this is the one baby
oh my God mtg's favorite rapper fellatio
blow
oh my god did you did you uh do get
copies made of his actual tattoos on his
face yeah dude look at this these are
real look look at that look at the
detail there it says it says Idiot
I got real tattoos dude and then I gotta
laze it off last night oh my God so you
wouldn't you wouldn't had the ink
dropped and then you had it taken off
after the bed yeah of course dude I I
got the ink I put it up I had crosses
and [__] and I had this like diamond
thing I had like Bitcoin thing back here
and then I had idiot in the front and uh
yeah yeah yeah I mean we take our
politics seriously here we really I mean
look when I commit to a bid right I
commit all the way balls deep uh and for
people wondering why is Gabe looking
like that and why did he show that
graphic earlier it's because it's part
of a what was that that's good that I
have on fellatio blow yeah and uh
Marjorie Taylor green I'm sure we'll be
showing this one next week
oh yeah yeah you'll see it Monday
because it'll it'll probably go out
later today
check out the what was that go to
patreon.com I'm Gabe Sanchez and you'll
see a little Bonafide conservative you
know what I'm saying boom that's the
best hat you've ever made by the way
honestly like I said last night so I I
uh I never buy the [__] hats or or
the the real like make America great or
major look or whatever it is I don't buy
those I just have a black a red hat and
then I put on I'm making a new sign and
I've had this I've had this for like two
years and I've never used it once
that Bonafide conservative yeah so it
isn't like you made this up for this bit
you've had it for a while Dude Perfect
I've got I'm a huge hypocrite I do my
own research I'm a Bonafide conservative
and I got another one
I forgot it's in the it's in the box of
God damn
in the closet back there what you're
saying Jesus Christ
Abraham Lincoln
Abraham true story in second grade I did
play and not by play I did a project on
Abraham Lincoln yeah and so I just went
around I was like I'm honest Gabe I'm on
his game that's my whole thing Honest
Game instead of Honest Abe mm-hmm oh
okay and then I became president it's
great
oh [__] can we move on now today
whatever right okay
um I look look we do serious stuff here
on the show if you're if you're
expecting to come here and get silliness
you're not that's not what you're gonna
get at all
right give me a second I'm gonna go I'm
gonna go
galactic the cuck makeup on I mean if
you wanted to you could have left the
cut makeup on I I wasn't saying that you
should take the cup hold on sticking to
my hair dude
is what the the beard is man I got I got
stuff to keep on the beer dude oh
so what hat is actually underneath them
what is the actual hint
what is it El Paso Chihuahuas dude oh
the El Paso Chihuahuas yeah it's a uh
but it's the red hat that you own yeah
yeah yeah and I've also got yours but
this is the one that I've like I've now
just done with this that's it that's it
yeah right so you just keep them okay so
I just keep it here I'll do this too
fellatio blow that is hilarious
oh my God I can't wait to see that one
next week oh by the way it's special I'm
speaking on Monday we got Tennessee
Brando on Monday oh even you don't know
that I contacted Tennessee Brando
yesterday I was like that come on I
played your I played your newest video
about Hunter Biden and them having
hard-ons for him I played that video and
I want to know and we played several of
his songs on here before so I was like I
want you to come on and talk about how
you make this music and how you come up
with this stuff how long it takes you to
write these things so Tennessee Brando
is going to join us on Monday and talk
about the new music that he's been the
country music that he's been running so
I'm super excited about that speaking of
music and fellatio below doing a
Marjorie Taylor Green song yeah yeah
it's it's I I'll say this I really go
into it dude I dig down into fellatio
blow you're saying you're because I I
know this I know this because of
screenshots you've sent me yeah but
you're saying that you're dressed up as
him in this video I am I mean dude I
just showed it I'll show it again I
literally show up like Fellatio blow in
the video in the night like I said when
I do people are like oh Gabe you make
these videos yeah dude I fully commit I
will do I'll do defects of stuff I'll
dress up I'll do props it's all it dude
I love it so so let me I can't I can't
not do it did you do the method acting
thing with the fellatio blow character
did you like we talked about yesterday
did you fully get into character and
yeah man
I got into I was walking down the street
and I was like I got the Adidas jumpsuit
on did you buy a truck with big tires
and everything
now I'm seventy thousand dollars in debt
the whole thing yeah
I got this custom decal of yeah of
Donald Trump
you know oh I see he's he's hugging me
from behind I see
on the truck yeah
[Laughter]
I mean honestly dude now now I I you
know I had the cost of getting tattoos
getting them lasered off this morning
buying a 70 000 truck with a ten
thousand dollar wrap job with Donald
Trump hugging me from behind uh yeah
while I was picking something up from
the ground right and when you hit the
horn it goes
[Music]
I don't know what's open serious serious
commentary always here on the Tony
Michaels podcast
I'm I'm here I'm here to deliver the
news and make it not so depressing or
boring okay I gotta admit so I I've
listened to NPR in my life and it's
boring as [__] let me listen yeah you're
pretty boring yeah well I mean you know
there's a planet money is pretty good
you know I don't know what you're
listening to well here's the thing
here's what I was gonna say I'm in a
trash I'm gonna trash people here and
people aren't gonna like this like yeah
I hate when Tony talks bad about people
on the left I'm like well they stop
being so [__] boring I wouldn't call
them boring I do have one qualm but it's
it's with yeah I guess it's with all
like NPR stuff but also anyone who does
like radio it's
like you hear that the mouse whatever
the [__] it's called I forget but you
hear when they're talking
the spit yeah and I'm like dude just
drink a bottle of water just turn the
mic up a little bit and back up from the
Sun yeah you can do it I don't need it
so goddamn hot don't have your money
ASMR the other thing too is speak up you
know yeah speak up use your [__]
voice welcome today's version of
bonafide conservative we're gonna get
deep and dirty into the politics of the
Le the left and the right wing and we'll
tell you exactly who's going down on who
right after our theme music
it's really [__] boring so I I I've
been listening or I've been trying to
listen to yeah yeah
um and I shouldn't even say this people
are gonna [__] knock me and I'm not
gonna say the exact shows so that you
know you can't really [__] with me but
I'm trying to listen to XM sxm the
progressive channel oh my God it's like
[__] NPR 2.0 my God damn you people
are [__] boring you're boring as [__]
have some have some personality yell and
scream a bit get excited talk about [__]
that you shouldn't be talking about
entertain people a little bit while
you're delivering them the depressing
[__] news that we got in this country
at least get them excited about it a
little bit you know what I mean and they
they don't express any kind of Rage
hardly it's like I'm really upset that
this is happening this is out free yeah
there are there are moments there are
moments well I don't listen to this I
don't have SiriusXM so I I can't I can't
you're not you're not a subscriber no I
mean I I barely listen to radio dude I
barely listen to myself oh man but when
I when I do listen to NPR I will will
have to agree in bed be in bed in bed
I got to sleep at 6 30 man it was great
uh no but when listening to them on the
radio like if I'm going from you know
wherever I'm traveling to uh I will have
moments where I'm like oh you guys do
have emotion like sometimes I get
excited about stuff about random stuff
and like oh yeah and they like laugh I'm
like holy [__] you guys are real right
uh but other times it's a lot of like
the same kind of like we're delivering
the news and we're neutral and I'm like
they have some you can have some good
stuff on NPR there's some game shows and
stuff that they have yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know I mean I'm not gonna say that
there's not good stuff on NPR but we
have a big you know wait wait don't tell
me yeah wait wait don't tell me that's a
good that's a great program yeah I grew
up less than that one that was that's
great I love wait wait don't tell me
that's great but but when you're when
you're listening to someone else you
know for hours at a time and it's just a
snooze Fest you get disappointed so
that's all I'm saying I'm not gonna call
out anyone's specific
because you get really mad at me if I
went after oh
the the all-time greatest of liberal
commentary and if you don't know who I'm
talking about big stuff has a question I
think it's a legitimate one in terms of
like can people cuss on the on serious
radio
well so so that's funny that's funny
that you say that okay because a lot of
people
I mean
let me give you a lesson on people
telling people what the [__] they can
and can't say when it's about politics
because I'm one of the people that
people tell me all the time and Gabe can
contest to this you shouldn't be saying
these things
politics you can say those words other
places because like on SiriusXM like on
Kevin Hart's channel on Alex turns out F
this F that [__] this [__] that
[__] this [__] that that on
and on and on it goes but you gotta
understand
those channels aren't politics Kevin
Hart is is comedy plus cussing not
politics plus cussing so they don't like
they don't like when cussing in politics
get involved like they don't like that
so it's not that they don't allow
cussing they just don't want cussing in
politics and the reason why is because
[__] corporate sponsors get all bent
out of shape when you when you pair the
f word [__] with politics I don't know
why I I don't understand it it's really
stupid I think it's dumb obviously I
think it's dumb because I do it every
day I couple the word [__] all I mean
Jesus Christ my entire brand is [__]
them the entire brand is it says it in
the goddamn intro [__] them hey Tony
[__] them
at the end it says [__] them whatever
you want from me that's just the brand
that I have
I didn't choose that brand by the way
that's a great story but anyways yes you
can cuss on XM but they don't like to
pair the political commentary with the f
word they don't like it they don't like
it and people and people get all kinds
of oh man but you oh you tell a good
joke with a good [__] F-bomb in it
boy we're all over that that's great
that's a great joke with the F-bomb in
it but whoa political commentary with
the f word
so I mean we're I'm hoping I can change
that but we'll see we will see let's get
to the bone of the week who are
boneheads here Donald Trump of course
Robert F Kennedy Jr RFK
Jason did you put James Aldine oh is
this is it Jason oops see I don't even
know the guy is it James on the pole I
don't know that's hilarious I didn't
notice that I mean this may be this may
be Jason's alternate person did I put it
in there maybe it autocorrected or maybe
I was like I don't [__] care about
this dude did it did you put James on
the pole hold on because if you did I
certainly did on YouTube
oh boy is it no I said Jason Jason yeah
okay so we're just wrong on this line
it's just on the slide here everyone
make sure make sure because make sure
you shake your finger at Gabe in the
chat it's Jason you're a bad boy you
know what you know you know what's funny
is I know right now he's he's kind of
laughing this off but this bothers the
ever-loving [__] out of him this bothers
you ever loving [__] out of this guy I
mean it by he's trying to laugh it up
right now live that it's wrong I'm
telling you deep down inside he's like
oh my God like he's mortified there's
the wrong name uh I mean it's close
enough so let's leave it up for a second
no I don't know I don't even [__]
care dude this guy's a piece of [__]
yeah dude he is a piece of [__] so
listen right isn't she yeah
transphobic She's Everything phobic yeah
well cookie cutter Barbie looking racist
homophobic transphobic bigoted person
that's what I got from the photos and
also some quick uh news articles yeah
yeah well here I I'll give you one one
picture that describes it all that you
need to know this is this is Jason
Aldean and then she ready and she's like
that's his wife and then Trump was like
someone made a picture um here let me
see if I can find her real quick and
then James was like oh yeah I'm a cook
Jason not James God damn it yeah James
so all of a sudden this motherfucker's
just gonna change his name because he
got the [__] graphic wrong here's
here's someone's here's someone's
rendition of this with this picture the
guy in the back's like cook
oh man I haven't even seen that graphic
and I just said that so it's like I you
know just same thing you know for James
listen a lot of people are knocking um
Jason Aldean not James but Jason Aldine
here for not writing the song like but
man honestly that's not the worst thing
that he did here right like a lot of
artists don't write all the songs they
record some of them they don't
they don't write music right
some of them some of them um write some
of their music other people write their
music for them I mean art art doesn't
necessarily be and to be an artist
doesn't necessarily mean that you wrote
the song you can record songs that are
written by I mean think of all the think
of all the uh redos that a great I mean
Johnny Cash
um re-recording hurt from nine years I
mean that's that's a great that's
fantastic that's a fantastic uh release
yeah of that song but so so I mean you
don't have to rank the song to be the
artist or to write a song to be uh the
greatest artist but Jason Aldean here
did some crazy [__] yeah as far as he
knew exactly what was going to happen
with this
um what is it what is it what is this
clip that you sent me here so this is
from The View
and it's regarding the song and I think
it's a it's a uh it's an educational
moment
where we should all kind of listen and
understand
while he may well you guys took it as
racist it's not racist understand where
this guy's from right and the imagery
that was used and look at that instead
of go oh look they're trying to silence
this guy the [__] cmt's super woke
right well let's let's listen here to
this clip from The View
your interpretation
because maybe he doesn't consciously
realize why a lot of people are not okay
with this song actually I need to really
listen I'm actually not going to give
him the benefit of the doubt and I'm
pleased that you are pleased that you
agree that he should be allowed to say
whatever because as a lawyer when I put
my legal hat on I don't believe in
censorship however this man is from
Macon Georgia my father's from Augusta
Georgia and Macon Georgia
I spent many Summers there yeah both I
spent many Summers there is one of the
most racist places in this country so
don't tell me that he knew nothing about
what that imagery meant and what he so I
don't give him the best but I'm saying
along with him more people should also
be the other thing is that what I what
was invoked for me which was you know I
you're not going to get out of this town
are those Sundowns yeah don't let the
serious go down
there were times when black people my
mother's in the audience today thank you
for coming
um
and my mother and father because they
were an interracial cup couple were run
out of South Carolina by the KKK
and my father is still scarred from that
experience and you are still scarred
from that experience so we're all still
scarves yeah so don't tell me that Not
only was he aware of what he was doing
by using that imagery he Embraces that
imagery and unfortunately this became
the number one
song on U.S iTunes we have a problem in
this country about race and the biggest
problem is we refuse to admit that it
exists well don't you think a lot of
this big city small town businesses
racist you want people okay so that is a
great clip and I want to point out
something that struck me in this clip is
that when they went to her mother
still alive this isn't like 400 years
ago this is like 200 years ago this
isn't like a hundred years ago her mom's
still alive well young her dad
apparently is still alive and well
and they were run out of a town in South
Carolina because they're an interracial
couple and and Jason Aldean acting like
well I don't know what you're talking
about that racism stuff that was
hundreds of years ago this is dumb
stupid [__] yeah and that's we are
nowhere close to a hundred years
in terms of where like when like the you
know the when things changed in terms of
legislation in the 60s right like we we
are we are not we we still have time to
go in terms of getting to oh that was a
hundred plus years ago it goes to the
point of our lifetimes our lifetime
all right our lifetimes it still won't
be 100 years ago exactly I remember [__]
that happened when Barack Obama was
elected the president United States in
2008 so it's going to be a long time
before you get to say a hundred years
ago but here's the other thing
um that she when she said about putting
her lawyer hat on because she's right
about the censorship thing you can't
stop him from seeing this music you
can't and anyone out there who wants to
stop Jason Aldean from singing this
music you're you're wrong you're wrong
he gets to record the music he wants to
record it doesn't mean you have to
listen to it it doesn't mean you have to
give it Credence it doesn't mean that
you have to make get relevant in the
social structure and in the social
conversation now some people thought
that it was particularly at this moment
and this time with this song with this
artist the way that he did it the way
they released it with the racist ass
[__] video
that exists with this and they knew what
the imagery was
if if he had the right to release it but
we also had the right to say that's
racist as [__] that's racist as [__] and
we don't have to listen to it CMT has
the right not to play it on their
[__] station if you remember
if you remember after 9 11
the Dixie Chicks at the time now they're
known as the chicks but at the time they
were known as the Dixie Chicks And I say
that's particularly because they dropped
Dixie from their name because some
people felt that it was offensive and
they felt so uh so strongly that they
dropped that part of their name from
from their name Dixie but then even then
they were known as the Dixie Chicks
right which the names to some degree
holds racism the the stench of racism
even in the name and even then when they
spoke out on stage against George W bush
they basically just called him a piece
of [__] and [__] him yeah they [__]
blacklisted the chicks from Radio they
wouldn't even play their song and it's
the same [__] that are pissed
off that CMT pulled down his song it's
the same [__] that wanted the
chicks off the radio same [__]
so don't be those [__] don't be
the [__] that says Hey I want
this to be censored but I don't want
this to be censored because I agree with
it what we need to do is we need to have
louder and better speech and that's why
I say like NPR is [__] boring and the
media is [__] boring and they get it
all wrong and the reason why they get it
wrong is because they're not loud enough
they don't have the correct style of
speech to fight this nonsense to fight
this [__] ignorance that Jason Aldean
and his wife perpetrate all over social
media those [__] racist [__]
scumbags I don't give a [__] what song
He's recording I wouldn't give him the
time of day I actually debated rather
I'd even listen to the [__] song but
I thought you know what I need to go
listen to the song at least once so I
can say I listen to the [__] and
not only not only is the video racist
this [__] and yes the lyrics are way off
track from what American small town is
not only that it's a garbage song if you
listen to it objectively it is a
horrible [__] song so but that goes
to the point of when Republicans say I'm
being silenced my voice is being
suppressed the government is doing this
all this like I'm pretty sure it was
like it's like number one on iTunes in
the same in the same regard that
fellatio Blow song went to number one
for his boycott Target thing which was
all based on this insane disinformation
campaign about people trying to cut off
little kids genitalia or that they were
giving children uh tuck uh type of
clothing right but none of that was
actually true they could never prove any
of that to be true because it doesn't
happen and it didn't happen and it
doesn't happen
and so when you have people like uh
James and Jason Aldean [__] and moan
about being canceled or being silenced
or whatever oh yeah okay yeah of course
they're gonna play that up because it's
going to drive sales it's going to get
attention it's going to make sure that
their song gets number one they're gonna
stream and they're gonna laugh their way
all the way to the [__] bank
but the same people like you said that
complain about that you can't have it
both ways
you can't cancel a company it's like
[__] Ron DeSantis what I'm probably
going to end up doing a what was that on
this this guy's out here now complaining
that Bud Light are in Bev it should be
sued because because their stock price
went down why the [__] do you think the
stock price went down you stupid
[__] it's because all of you
Republican Maga idiots decide to say hey
we're going to cancel this thing because
we sent a one a singular novelty can to
Dylan Mulvaney
a trans influencer from Tick Tock
someone that you would never encounter
you know it's not a can you know what's
funny they do the same thing for right
wing influencers
on social media they send the same kind
of promotional marketing money to
right-wing influencers
so as and and honestly I'm surprised the
left didn't catch on to this where they
went and found the right wing like you
know what we should cancel Bud Light
because it's the same [__] when you're
saying when you're saying when you're
saying I don't want Jason Aldean's song
played I I and you don't want it to be
number one then stop talking about it
and I I actually I waited for two
[__] days two days to not talk about
the Aldine song and the reason why I
didn't even want to talk about the [__]
is because I didn't want to give him any
kind of light a day because he doesn't
[__] deserve any kind of light a day
anywhere [__] him but everyone kept
talking about it they kept going on and
on about it and I couldn't ignore it
anymore it was a dereliction of my duty
not to say something about that [__]
song about that [__] scumbag Jason
Aldean [__] him [__] him [__] him [__]
him
but I I couldn't ignore it anymore so we
put him on the bone net of the week and
you know hopefully that idiot I'm going
to be honest I have never heard of Jason
or James Aldean I've never heard it I've
never heard of James either well yeah
dude I'm just telling you I have never
heard of Jason Aldean until this all of
this happened right and that could be
because I don't listen to Country but I
know kind of the main core people right
but at the same time like never heard of
that guy in my [__] life and the only
reason I heard of him was because people
were like yeah he's getting canceled
he's not getting canceled
he tell me tell me one way in which this
white man this country singer has been
canceled
CMT didn't want to play the song okay
well that's it uh whatever tell me how
right his life has been impacted again
tell me how that his life is any way
comparable to anyone else who has
actually who is actually experienced any
sort of suppression or oppression for
that regard in their life because I can
guarantee Jason Aldean has an
experienced [__] now he probably was on
the giving end of the oppression to
people in his town or to other people
who don't look like him right well the
other the other thing I want to mention
too about the back to the chicks the
chicks not only had one song canceled
they had all their songs canceled the
entirety and it's almost like it's
almost like it's because they're women
is the reason why they blacklisted the
chicks when they spoke out against
George W bush on Thursday yeah they were
right hmm
well you know Republicans don't like
Republicans don't like people who who
actually speak truth well they don't
like women and they don't like women
well that's good well speaking of people
who don't like women Donald Trump was
also
what I honestly I can't even remember
why now why why oh because he said he
was gonna he got the target letter is
that right is that why uh is that why we
put him on this yeah I think I don't
know if you put him on that I mean it
was the target letter and then the video
where he's like uh you [__] you
better not [__] with us
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I'm not even
gonna play that he's just a bone-in he
just he's just a regular bearing button
so there he is there he is Donald Trump
um let's go let's go to um our other uh
dishonorable mentions and alpha x here
let's go the advocac first James Comer
here so I'm sure there's like four or
five instances this week where he got
cooked oh what's what's what's the one
that you put him and because you chose
the amplica here what's the one the main
the main one was because it was a
[__] you know Hot Potato between him
and Jim Jordan yeah it was all this
whistleblower talk and saying you know I
think you've got the clip right now or
one of them well I've got one that's
very interesting right yeah James Comer
but it's Ted Cruz asking James Comer
some questions oh yeah even Ted Cruz
isn't convinced here it's just because
it always comes back it always comes
back to this idea that Joe Biden did
something wrong and if that and if that
is true and if that's the case and he
took five million 10 million 40 million
whatever the [__] number is
then he should be held accountable if
you can prove that he did what you say
he did
then you should have no problem showing
the evidence you should have no problem
keeping track of your informants making
sure that your whistleblowers aren't
Chinese or Iranian spies you should have
no problem
you should have an open and shut slam
dunk case for the amount of the length
of time and the amount that they've
talked about this they should have no
problem to say Joe Biden we have him on
X date y date Z date doing these things
saying these things taking money
because right now all we're doing is uh
well okay well it hasn't happened yet uh
you guys it's like that Mr Bean like GIF
where he's just like
he's just waiting in the field
or it's even John Travolta from [__]
Pulp Fiction he's like uh where the hell
is it where's
that's what we're doing but also in the
same sense like people on the left are
like yeah we all thought this was going
to happen this way people on the right
are like where are the indictments where
are the charges
that's the rake that they're stepping on
here right yeah let's let's watch as
this this is weird [__] this is weird
stuff I'm gonna tell you this is the Ted
Cruz verdict podcast I guess and James
Comer singing now they've changed the
set I noticed which is very interesting
he's moved from the leather couches
because that seemed I'm I'm gonna be
honest uh one dude sitting in a like
Lexington style leather couch smoking a
cigar in an empty room with the big
screen and a mic
talking to people or talking at people
seemed pretty elitist to me Tony I mean
now now he's going for the Zodiac News
man apparently that's what he's I think
that's what he's going to transition to
Ted Cruz is transitioning from United
States Center you would also think that
people who are in the Senate or in
Congress say Hey My My My schedule my
workload
it's pretty full right now like I've got
a I've got a home a personal life in my
family cruise works
on top of having a family and being like
hey my life is kind of crazy
family time would you hey if you were if
you were in Ted Cruz's family would you
want him to do family time I mean he's
got three daughters and him and his wife
are like Barbies are evil like all of a
sudden Barbies are evil now that there's
a movie they're like
we've got to find all Barbies he's gotta
find any way possible to say that
anything that is
female empowerment or feminism or
anything is communist because if you
actually see the movie that's why I want
to see it because Texas hates it if
Kevin I want to go see it there's a map
there's a map to of the world right and
it's a bunch of it's a it's a random map
that's not like geographically accurate
right it's like an outline and then
colors and some words and some like oh
it's squiggle lines Oh you mean it's you
mean you mean it's not supposed to be
real because Barbie isn't real is that
what you're saying wait Barbie's not
real if you see the movie you might be
like oh that Barbie's real okay but
that's what they're complaining about
and even even a historical I forget his
full title but this historian was like
Ah that's not a thing that this is not
this is not what people are making out
to be and now that's The Narrative of oh
it's the seven dash line or whatever it
is that you know and they're like oh I
guess it's so dumb it's so dumb and
they're just trying to find any way
possible to make sure that a movie that
is
that has a diverse cast that is actually
well written and well executed and well
directed and has uh a good story like
again I went to the movie not really
knowing anything about it other than
like oh okay it's gonna be Barbie and
Ken and
before halfway things [__] turn and I
was like oh I didn't really expect this
and then like later on I'm like oh I had
no idea this was gonna happen
now I want to see it even more that's
great let's go to the alpha cook but
what pay attention to this clip here
even Ted Cruz isn't convinced which is
wild [__] watch I think that Joe Biden
has been selling access to our enemies
for decades I think that so long before
Hunter was involved awesome so let me
stop you on that you said he's been
selling access to our enemies for
decades that that
on the face of it is an extraordinary
statement what's your basis for that
basis is you know if you study Joe Biden
like I have uh he's always been cash
he's never had a successful career in
investing or anything like that then you
look at the assets he's accumulated on
the Senate salary
it's pretty pretty impressive and you
look at the upkeep to those assets I I
believe that if we you know so you're
saying a classic Corvette done by itself
hold on hold on hold on uh when was okay
first off when was the last time Joe
Biden was a Senator it's been a while
okay it's been probably like I don't
know like 15 years it's been a while
it's been a while something like that
uh okay oh 16 maybe uh
also tell me
is this okay and what they're saying
what Ted Cruz said at the air in there
too is a classic Corvette does it by
itself so what he's saying is is that
the only way Joe Biden owns a classic
Corvette which he's owns uh several
Corvettes what I understand just one of
these is a classic one that you see in a
lot of the the political ads because
it's a really nice [__] vet yeah it's
a really nice [__] car but it's not
any more expensive than like a eat truck
right with the big Trump flags and the
Big old tires and all that [__] I mean
like you're like nine thousand there's
like 90 000 trucks those trucks are
insane like I said for this video I won
seventy thousand dollars in debt and and
and and the thing is is that this
classic Corvette probably doesn't cost
much more than a brand new you know
jacked up truck with big old tires and a
big old Trump Flags right yeah and and
the Trump [__] I mean it also depends
on when he got it right so like you have
to imagine like right if you purchase if
either purchase it 25 years ago it was a
lot less than so this idea that the only
reason why Joe Einhorn is because he was
selling secrets to our enemies you
people are dumb is dog [__] the other
thing too is when James covers like I've
been I've been skirting Joe Biden for a
long time and he doesn't seem like the
kind of guy that can make good
Investments although he is the kind of
guy that knows how to run the economy I
mean yeah yeah you know what I mean you
know I mean
you may not know he may not know the
proper stock to invest in but he sure as
hell knows how to run of economy I
actually believe that Joe Biden probably
my guess is
from from seeing Biden and knowing what
I know about him me studying him for a
long time I crawled up his ass and
really studied what his Investments were
but here's the thing just looking at Joe
Biden my guess is is that Joe Biden is
the kind of person who's like who's the
best
um investment advisor that I can find
and I want that person to advise me on
what to invest in that's probably what
he would do because that's just
generally what he does even in real life
when he's like who's the best person to
tap for this job I'll go to them and
I'll make sure that I take their their
[__] advice on what to do on this and
I'll really think hard about what
they're saying and I'll probably make my
decisions based on what an expert says
against kind of his history but you know
that you know James Comer researched him
you know like on on the deep dark web on
eight Chan he did a lot of research on
8-chan he knows everything there is no
he did so much research on Joe Biden and
the money that he's taken that they have
not presented actual evidence for a guy
I mean at this point it's kind of like
stalkerish in a way because the guy is
absolutely obsessed with Joe Biden
because really he has these people like
Margaret Taylor green she's got Hunter
Biden's dick pics that's literally her
platform that is all she has she has
nothing else to run on she's doing these
dumbass cringy music videos with rap
stars that I've rapped about killing and
shooting their girlfriends and then
throwing their body in a lake uh they
they've raped about drug use they've
wrapped that sounds like a really that
sounds like a Christian Conservative
Christian it sounds like a a very family
uh family oriented right yeah yeah and
so you've got people like Margaret
Taylor green James Comer Jim Jordan Jim
Jordan has not introduced slash past
legislation and the whole time he's been
in Congress that guy is so incompetent
he didn't even know how to swear someone
in at the beginning of their of their
Committee hearing yesterday with RFK JR
this is these are the dumb these are the
idiots these are the [__] idiot kids
who are running our government they are
the people who are so so determined so
absolutely determined to say there is
corrupt Biden family members Joe Biden
is corrupt they took millions of dollars
no evidence if that's the case not a
shred show the evidence you guys have
been talking about this since last year
if not before that well listen listen to
this clip this will get you this is on
the this is on the Zodiac newsman's
podcast dude let's listen I think that
that Obama knew this was going on
towards the end and I think that's why
Obama didn't want Biden to run for
president I don't think it had anything
to do with his age I don't think he can
do that with the gas I think he never
underestimated the ability for Joe Biden
f it up
so so they're saying that Obama didn't
want Biden to run Obama I don't do they
remember 2020 at all
Obama the Obama backed Biden
well 120 percent what the [__] are they
talking about Obama didn't want Biden to
be president what the [__] are they
talking about it they're they're trying
to
they're making sure they're trying to
drive an imaginary wedge between two
people who are honestly
kind of like the best of friends while
they were in the [__] Administration
together you know they did all sorts of
stuff together they got ice cream they
drove around they worked out they did
laps around the [__] white house
together the two of them
are not enemies the two of them are are
[__] Amigos man they are simpatico
baby
but the idea that that you oh I also can
you go back to the oil you're gone now
but I don't know who the guy is that's
too I don't know behind Ted Cruz
but Ted Cruz and this other guy it's
hilarious to watch these three very
subpar men
sit there and be let's talk about Joe
Biden uh let's talk about the news on
how Joe Barton took money well a
Corvette is going to pay for itself uh
don't uh uh I mean you can always make
sure that Joe Biden is gonna have it up
like
tell me something
that's actual proof here show me let me
show you let me show you let me let me
show you let me show you this is from
RNC research account so you know that
it's rock solid here
um it says Biden is rewarded with Ice
Cream Sandwich after finishing his
speech in Philadelphia literally this is
what the RNC research account is doing
where Joe Biden is eating ice cream
sandwiches and giving ice cream
sandwiches to the union workers there
he's passing them out as I hear you get
a sandwich you get a sandwich you get
the dude likes ice cream yeah and who
doesn't like a good ice cream an ice
cream sandwich it is the [__] summer
I'm dead serious though this is real
this is not parody this is the official
RNC research account and they posted
this [__] video with Biden is
rewarded with Ice Cream Sandwich after
finishing his speech in Philadelphia
they're such dumb [__] man that this is
how desperate they are this is they're
also desperate in that this is not the
first time they've cut a clip without
context or they've cut Clips to say you
don't need guys to eat oh no I know I
know he's having ice cream with the
union workers what the [__] yeah it
doesn't make any sense believe me it
does not make any sense on how this is a
disc if I was working I mean these
people are working in Philly again it is
the summer time do you know how warm and
humid it gets on the East Coast during
July June July August [__] man it's a
heat wave out here in LA right now
it's always hot I would love an ice
cream sandwich if I was working in a job
where I know I'm probably sweating
looking at the people that are the union
workers there and I'm standing in in
that that site I'd be like yeah I'll
take a [__] ice cream sandwich
a free cold thing that's delicious oh
[__] Ed man I'll take it
but this is what the RNC research group
and other people like Trump and Ted Cruz
and James Comer and Jim Jordan and Matt
Gates and all these other [__] idiots
like Roger Taylor green and Lauren
Boberg they think it's some discs
like again this is what you guys are
focusing on you're focusing on dick pics
ice cream sandwiches and unreal
imaginary informants and whistleblowers
that is what they're complaining they're
complaining about woke washing machines
inflation that's gone down
job numbers that have gone up I told you
everything I totally didn't just quote
tweet that so you can find it and go uh
yeah
so dumb because that is their only
argument they've realized that every
time they come for it and it's like man
you you think someone in that party was
like hey maybe we shouldn't do this
but the fact that they keep trying they
keep trying these dumb things these oh
man we got them now we owned them so
good and it's like where was this burn
you know what else about this video
that's really funny is Joe Biden's like
sharing ice cream sandwiches with the
with the workers there and what was it
last week Trump walks into a Dairy Queen
in Iowa and he's like what the hell is a
blizzard what the hell is a blizzard
yeah I don't know what because he
doesn't know what a blizzard Dairy Queen
Blizzards and there's video out there
and I think I post I think I played on
the show or dark but he also Brandon
knows what you do with a blizzard you
turn it upside down like but not only
does he know what a blizzard is dark
Brandon knows what a blizzard is he
knows that you got to turn it upside
down before you get it somebody he knows
that's the problem it's it's crazy
because again you know just like they'll
go after Joe Biden for stuttering or
having it you know a speech uh Speech
issues uh if he's given a speech or
something like that or you know they
won't go after RFK Jr who has his own
speech issues right it's very difficult
to understand what he says because he
has a speech yeah he has but he's a
Democrat so why aren't they attacking
him he's a Democrat oh that's because
he's Maga well we're going to get into
that but let's start with this
megalodite first this piece of [__]
trash the governor of Texas uh Greg
Abbott I've seen it you put him in as a
dishonorable mention he deserves a hell
of a lot worse than dishonorable Mansion
uh this [__] piece of [__] so um Beto
O'Rourke tweeted earlier about the this
uh uh mother and her and her two
children I believe her were killed
crossing the river
um but you put him on and they have no
and these Republicans these people who
claim to be pro-life they're not are not
pro-life no they laugh
at people dying the truth the cruelty is
the point though yeah no at 100 but they
they
watch as if it's a game like it's sport
oh let me throw in [__] barbed wire
let's drown these people let's kill
these innocent people who are just
looking for a better opportunity the the
opportunity that this country is
supposedly all about
look at these [__] immigrants dying
in the river are you really the other
thing too is that they believe every
whistleblower that believes in what they
believe uh they're not going to listen
to this whistleblower here uh Beto
O'Rourke post this Whisperer letter
makes clear the Abbott's Troopers are
funneling Asylum Seekers towards
dangerous parts of the river or they are
more likely to drown uh that's how this
mother two people are dead so uh their
children
um so this is The Whistleblower letter
here and it talks about how they're
funneling them to this certain part this
certain passing on the river and the
idea is to to deter them because they're
the idea is that oh you'll be the danger
is too much no these people want to come
to this country that bad they want a
better life here that bad
that is why they are crossing the river
that is why they're coming to this
country and they're willing to do
anything to get here because their lives
are in danger if they don't you [__]
idiots
and you you [__] scumbags now a lot
of people are are knocking on the Biden
Administration to get Texas to stop this
and I think the Department of Justice is
probably going to move in here on on
your big habit I would imagine
especially after now that we know that a
mother and her two children were killed
and you can't tell me you you you you
can't honestly tell me that if
Republicans were in the same position
they something happened in America or
whatever the country that they might be
in
and they had to say look we need to
leave we need to go we need to make sure
that our family is safe for a group of
people that talk about family values and
protecting their family and their wife
and their kids and all that dumb [__]
all those dumb arguments they make about
being pro-life and wanting wanting to
make sure that they protect their own
guns two second amendment all that dumb
[__] age get rid of education and all
yeah you're gonna tell me that if
Republicans were
in the same boat
they wouldn't try to do that [__] they
wouldn't try to escape to to cross the
river to make sure that their family was
safe
or Cross or cross to another country so
they could provide for their family back
in the country that they're originally
from
like Republicans are the people who are
like pull yourself up about your
bootstraps you gotta survive it's
survival the fittest you got to do what
you got to do to make sure that you and
your family and your next of kin are
safe
well if that's true
then why would you not extend the same
opportunity to the people who are not
like you because they're brown because
they're brown that's why exactly that's
right they're [__] racist that's what
that's why I I thought I thought you
were asking me the question no I mean I
mean it's rhetorical but yeah I know
that's why we'll say it out loud I don't
give a [__] I'll say it all day out loud
the reason why Greg Abbott is okay with
the mother and her two children drowning
in the river funneling them to this part
of the river where they'll drown or get
caught up in the snag wire and drown is
because he doesn't like them because
they're brown that's why that's why
they're they're [__] their their skin
color their name where they're from he
didn't like them because he's a racist
piece but they love to say well I'm not
racist I've got a brown friend right
exactly
I mean you know we know we know what you
joke about we know what you say we know
how you feel
Republicans are
racist to their core whether they want
to admit it or not some people are very
out there and they're like yep that's
who I am some people like I'm not racist
I got a brown person that cleans my
house for me
um and I I believe that the Department
of Justice is going to swoop in on this
if they haven't already I don't know if
they filed any kind of injunction
against Abbott for the snag the snag
operations because if you don't know
what they're doing is they're laying
they're laying um they're laying snag
snag buoys and snag wire in these rivers
and then what they're doing is they're
they're they're they're kind of
funneling these people and trying to
coerce them in that area where they can
snag them in the river and the the snag
the snag wire is a snag and drowned it's
designed to snag and drown to whatever
it snags that's the design so they're
funneling these these these women and
children uh too I mean I just want to
know how long it's going to take before
this becomes like
you know um here here here actually
actually uh here it is
um uh it says doj will sue them uh Beto
has it on his page here let me let me
bring it up
um so that we have some more
uh that it's today and it just it just
happened an hour ago that he posted this
um so you say breaking fed Sue Abbott uh
over drowning device in Rio Grande
um it let's keep up the pressure
we want the buoys and netting removed
and the razor wire under the water and
on the banks removed for DPS to respect
border patrol Authority now before more
die and you can see here it's kind of
this is the Houston Chronicle I'll
retweet this but uh the Houston
Chronicle the headline is doj says it
will sue Texas over Bowie wall barrier
in Rio Grande River but you can see it
you can see the buoys here they're
they're like round balls but they got
snag wire on them and they're designed
where you can't go under them or over
them and it's supposed to snag you and
pull you under
and hold you under the water I don't
know if people know this but as a human
you can't breathe underwater normally
that's not and and it's you can normally
can't hold your breath for you know more
than a minute or two most most people
some people can get to three or four
minutes but you gotta have you know you
got to build a tolerance for three or
four minutes but the design is to hold
you under the water and I don't know if
you know this but when you're held
underwater for a certain amount of time
you [__] drowned
it's not obligated to understand it yeah
so it also It also says the state of
Texas actions violate federal law raise
humanitarian concerns present serious
risks to Public Safety and the
environment and may interfere with the
federal government's ability to carry
out its official duties the department
wrote according to a copy obtained by
hers newspapers it's again you know this
is I I wanted the same thing is like how
long does it take before this becomes a
humanitarian crisis there they are they
are for it's not like oh here are the
natural conditions that exist this is
man-made and they're putting them in
this position right and the fact that
they're [__] razor wire man well and
they're they're directing these people I
also want to point out something in this
picture here which is very significant
if you look here right here right here
there's a guy in a hard hat standing in
the river you see the the Machinery here
this is an excavator is what they call
this with the bucket on the end why
would you need that well but while
they're installing they're installing
these is what they're doing but look but
look how look how shallow the river is
here I mean usually usually these treads
on these excavators are you know about
three feet high so it's less than you
know three feet and they're pushing this
out into the river where it's a shallow
part of the river and the reason why is
because that's where people cross
because it's savored across on a shallow
part of the river because I don't know
it's probably safer to stand in the
river than try to swim all the way
across with the current so there's snap
they're putting these snagging drowns in
these areas where these people were
likely to cross and then they're trying
to funnel them to these areas to snag
and drown them the cruelty is the point
folks it's the same cruelty they used
when they separated and kidnapped kids
from their family when they cross the
border under the Trump Administration
the cruelty is the point they think if
they're cruel enough that people will
not try to get into this country that's
what they think and they're wrong
they're wrong people want to come to
America it is the greatest country on
Earth according to you conservatives why
wouldn't you think people would cross a
river to get here you [__] boneheads
anyways okay I love to stay on that but
we're we're running low on time so I
really got to get to the winner
I really got to get to the winner and
we'll stay on that uh Texas story as it
unfolds hopefully hopefully they'll get
a federal injunction to pull that P that
pull that [__] out of the river so it
ain't [__] killing people uh in the
river trying to get into the desperate
to get into this country to live the
American dream with the American flags
and all the fake ass [__] history
that these white Supreme welcome welcome
to America the land of razor wire and
snagging drowns okay yeah okay great
Abbott you [__] piece of [__] okay
let's move on to the winner we had uh
Donald Trump RFK Jr and Jason Aldean
otherwise known as James Aldean today
um but our our winner is Robert F
Kennedy Jr RFK made a complete [__]
utter fool of himself yesterday in a uh
a hearing it was and I had to I had to
applaud him he did a wonderful job
he needed an absolute amazing job at
proving us all right right and helping
our case and giving a huge rake in the
face for Republicans like Jim Jordan
James Comer Thomas Massey Lauren bobert
Marjorie Taylor green
Kevin McCarthy every one of these people
who are who are under this assumption
that if they keep going with the same
strategy it's going to change like they
keep doing it's literally Insanity they
keep doing the same thing expecting a
different outcome and every single time
they come up with something like this
one's gonna be the one we're going to
really own those lips today and it's
like no you [__] idiots you're doing
the same thing before except it's a
different topic you guys don't do any
research or you think that Democrats
won't do any research like
we've got the tapes we've got the the
recordings we've got testimony we've got
written statements we've got you on in
literal 4K saying these racist things
against these communities
and you can't you can't now have this
revisionist tale as a as a witness of
you know as RFK Jr because that's right
that's all that it was I'm chuckling and
what you're saying is funny but what I'm
looking at on my screen because we have
breaking news here it's hilarious it's
hilarious oh
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry you know I I did
a video about Rand Paul's neighbor
um
uh several years ago and I think it goes
something like this
um you know uh it's a Genie Genie in a
lamp I grant you one wish and I said
Genie make me Rand Paul's neighbor
um that would be the one I wish I had
but um apparently and I'm gonna turn the
sound off on this but um apparently
right now uh one of Rand Paul's offices
is on fire and they're putting it out
with that socialist
hey these Kami water trucks these Kami
fire water trucks are putting out uh
Rand Paul's free market value property
there wherever this is I'm putting out
the fire I don't know why he's agreeing
insurance fraud I don't know why he's
com I don't know why he's agreeing to
this type of socialism yeah we're a
taxpayer-funded truck would come with
water and put his thing out then he he
doesn't believe in that kind of [__]
does he I mean socialist socialist oh
please this is look at this this is a
bunch of communist environments suits
with this red ret commy red commie red
water truck putting out his [__]
office building the hose oh dude this is
so gay it's gay and Tommy woke Jesus yay
I mean the hose that's a penis Tony
Brian I'm okay what is that stuff coming
out of it looks like it that's what
Republicans thinking and then hooking up
hooking up to these communist uh fire
hydrants to pump this water Jesus Christ
don't you know all the government money
that was spent to put those hydrants and
those commie red those red calming fire
hydrants oh they got like four spraying
out at the same time
Tony no Jesus
oh sorry I couldn't help it I just yeah
no I mean
Rand Paul was trending I'm like what's
this and his his [__] office building
is burning down
so I'm like oh okay I mean the whole
Republican party is on fire it's not
surprising at their office buildings are
literally Catching Fire here
oh boy okay so what what were we talking
about what was that um oh yes oh yes our
winner RFK Junior sorry I I lost track
of what we were talking about wait it
happened in Bowling Green yeah is that
that's not the same Bowling Green that
uh
that you mean the Bowling Green Massacre
yeah that's not the same bowling or
NASCAR right I mean you mean kellyanne
Conway was like oh this is
the same one this is a real Bowling
Green this is not the same one that
Kelly I mean there are there's a lot of
states that have towns that are called
Bowling Green Oh there's actually some
colleges and it may be bowling or in
Kentucky where there's a Bowling Green
uh if you played them one year now years
ago I went to a an mu game where they
played it was their first match you know
in these these big universities always
get a small school to come so they kick
the [__] out of them a lot of times
they'll pay him like a million bucks to
come play to come play them so they just
kick the ever lemon [__] out of them and
uh mu played Bowling Green I think it's
called Bowling Green University or
something like that and I don't know if
it's Bowling Green Kentucky but a lot of
states have a town named both yeah like
Springfield right exactly right and a
lot of a lot of a lot of uh well if we
find out this is insurance fraud don't
say agility so right well you know
oh I bet it was Anthony fauci I'm just
saying I'm just saying could have been
maybe maybe it is
[Music]
okay what were we talking oh yeah RFK
Junior sorry I keep getting off track
here sorry we'll get back on here in a
second I just had to poke fun at uh um
Rand Paul he's an easy target and I
haven't made fun of him for a while well
you know it's not hard to make fun of
the mop head but what do you do yeah
well when you do it you got to do it
okay um let's go to RFK Jr here let's
see if I can pick out a few oh yes this
this is a great one uh let's see should
we do the Nazi one or the oh let's let's
do this one where he gets really upset
and Jim Jordan has to get time back to
Debbie Wasserman Schultz this is pretty
much a good example of how it went all
day yesterday I never said that yes you
did you literally did I have I have
quotes from video play the tape let's so
let's play the clip because again this
clip kind of encapsulates in just a
minute and a half of how RFK Junior's
day went yesterday in this hearing Phil
fuels deadly violence today yet last
week you floated a baseless conspiracy
theory that the coronavirus was
bioengineered to Target Caucasians and
black people but to spare Ashkenazi Jews
and Chinese people Mr Kennedy your
bizarre unproven claim Echoes that same
historic slander of labeling Jews and
Chinese people as a race and that Jews
and in this case Chinese people somehow
managed to avoid a deadly illness that
targets other groups for death you do
see that yes or no you're meditating no
no no no I quoted what you said earlier
and it is directly what you said so just
ask
I was describing an NIH fund it's study
that's not what you said I was
describing an nih-funded study by
Cleveland clinics claiming my time
reclaiming my time
reclaiming published in USC medical
which is nine the time is mine I'm
reclaiming it please ask the witness to
stop talking you asked me a question
reclaiming let me allow me to answer my
question Mr chairman I'd like about 10
seconds the time the time
like you are citing here now during that
conversation you referenced no study at
all you simply labeled Jews and Chinese
people as a race and you also said that
somehow they managed to avoid a deadly
illness that targets other groups for
death you don't see that you're trying
to rewrite history here a few months ago
oh my God I bet he's waiting I I mean
like I don't know what his wife Cheryl
Hines the actress like her views are on
all this stuff
but I can't imagine she's like oh God
damn it I mean not obviously there's a I
gotta let me see if I can find this
quote really quick there was a uh it was
because Cheryl Hines is in Curb Your
Enthusiasm which also has
um
uh
uh uh Larry David and and there's a
there's a quote that was about
it says
Kennedy Kennedy says I feel a lot of
support and love from most of her
friends Cheryl Hines okay including
including Larry as in Larry David oh
okay what did Larry David have to say
about then however in a text to uh New
York Times David shared a slightly
different sentiment stating yes love and
support but I'm not supporting him
so right like like it would be like I
really want the guy to seek help I
really I liked it yeah I I really want
to support him
he's not all there he's got he's got his
Grizzlies that kind of support right
yeah yeah like if you got a family
member or someone you love that has an
addiction or is kind of not all there
and they need some medical attention
like medical attention mental health
care or something he would be in support
of them getting it exactly that's what
Larry David it also kind of felt like
when someone's like oh yeah he's my best
friend or we're friends or whatever and
then the other is like are we
I mean like right I mean we hung out
once at a cocktail party right when's
the last time we spoke
the friends on Facebook and you know
that that's not really yeah like I you
follow me right on Twitter but I've
never talked to you yeah so the fact
that you know RFK Jr is like oh yeah all
of her friends love and support me
including Larry David and Larry Davis
like nope not a thing not really nope I
mean that's also the most it's also the
most Larry David response and he's like
uh yeah 11 sport uh I'm not supporting
him though
but yeah you can say whatever you want
that I'm doing right here here's a
follow-up of that same clip so here's
the end of that same clip where it got
cut off
um I'm gonna play that and then I'm
gonna play you
him saying what he says she sang he said
but he did say but he'd say he didn't
say it's [__] it's [__] lunatic see
that you're trying to rewrite history
here a few months ago Mr Kennedy you
compared covid Public Health policies to
barbaric murderous tactics of Nazi
Germany saying the Jewish people in Nazi
Germany had more freedom than Americans
facing coveted Health restrictions in
hindsight Mr Kennedy do you reject this
absurd and deeply hurtful and harmful
comparison or do you still stand by it
Congressman what you are saying is a lie
okay what she's saying is a lie that's
what he's saying okay well let's go to
the tape I'll pull it up here can you
get the studio to play the game for us
can you guys get that uh clip okay let's
get the clip here oh oh this looks like
the same guy is this the same guy he's
taking a [__] apparently it looks like
he is in the bathroom yesterday
yesterday when I saw this clip I was
like oh he's wearing a robe like I
honestly I definitely thought that he
was in in some some part of his house
where he was wearing a robe and he's
like I woke he's like I woke up all
conspiracy like this right see the other
thing too is you wouldn't set up a
camera and record in your bathroom
because it's really echoey in there yeah
the Acoustics are not great for
singing sure but recording you're
recording absolutely [__] they're
absolute [__] but let's listen to let's
see what he says about
um not saying not comparing because he
said you're what you're saying is a lie
that he did not compare let's see
they're gonna have the right to compel
unwanted medical interventions on us we
you know the Nazis did that in the camps
I I mean I think he's saying uh it means
it's just me I think he's comparing the
Nazis did that in the camps to to the
covet vaccine I think that's what he's
doing it's almost like yesterday I'm
just gonna was a lie yeah I'm just gonna
do what was that and it's gonna be like
here's here's the Committee hearing and
I'm like let's roll that beautiful game
it's you and then it's just him saying
that and you gotta have this dog though
like dude yeah I know I forget what the
dog's name but he's like roll that
beautiful Bean footage and then it cuts
to him doing it and then you're just
gonna play the Curb Your Enthusiasm
outro
oh RFK Jr you certainly are a bonehead
and you know the best part about this it
the rake that Republicans stepped on
because here's the thing they were
hoping for they were hoping that most
the country we listened to RFK Jr in
this hearing and they'd be like yeah
weaponization to government their common
actor yet they're going to get you
citizens and I'm a Democrat and I'm the
one that's gonna Gonna Save You Duke
Duke is the name of the Duke but here's
the thing here's the thing yesterday it
it just gave more Credence and more
proof of why Joe Biden shouldn't have to
debate this [__] idiot like anyone
saying that he that Joe Biden should
Abate this idiot now number one he he's
not competent enough to debate someone
on a stage because he doesn't even know
that he can't shut his [__] you have to
shut your [__] mouth when you're
being when you're testifying in Congress
you can't just talk over the person who
has the time which is a congress person
he should know this he's a Kennedy for
crying out loud I mean don't Kennedys
know everything about everything because
her name's Kenny that's dumb [__] too so
it only it only tore down the entire
narrative that RFK is a viable candidate
in the Democratic party because he's not
a Democrat yesterday proved he's not a
Democrat he's not one he's just he's
Maga he might as well trade in his
[__] card he's not a Democrat number
two I mean we know he's hung out with uh
Michael Flynn right boy he's bannon's
boys yeah Roger Stone and bannon's boy
that's the reason why he's in this race
he proved it yesterday and he proved
that he's the biggest [__] bonehead
of the week you voted you decided he was
a bonan of the week Gabe Sanchez let's
give him his due
[Music]
[Applause]
you know it'd be funny if we got a cease
and desist because we called him James
Aldean and just like that would be
awesome they're like hey whoa
[__] yeah I'm not I'm more or
there is a James L Dean and it's his
twin brother and we just revealed this
crazy story nobody knew about until
right now because of my little hiccups
if you watch his videos he does hand
signals and the one hand signal is James
Aldean and the other one is Jason Aldean
that's that's how you know that's how
you know okay okay and there's specific
meganomics and dematria that yeah look
I'm I'm no uh
magnomics you know Aficionado I'm not a
magnet I have I have a degree in
meganomics thing yeah well that's great
well I'm not a magnominus so it didn't
take very long it didn't take I'm sure
it took just as long as for people to
become uh epidemiologists or
constitutional lawyers
lawyers or whatever it might be every
single person during covet was like I'm
an expert most of those people were Maga
someone's bringing back the old Cheeto
chop
it was that a couple weeks ago that you
did the Gino job I feel like it was a
few weeks ago it was it more than a
couple I don't know yeah I don't know
chop
oh yeah God damn best audience in the
world that's Bonet of the week that's
you but don't go anywhere we're gonna
play the music here but we got a few
announcements I think I gotta clip the
players I'm like don't go anywhere we'll
be right back right after the music
[Music]
[Applause]
bone end of the week bonehead of the
week James Aldean James maybe I'll
listen to James Aldean's music now it's
a good thing it's a good thing he didn't
win because it would have been all kinds
of [__] weirdness Jason Aldean
actually won but we show that James
Aldean yeah this isn't it
it would really pull the the legitimacy
of the bone into the weak pool hey what
a question you you the audience would
have questioned the legitimacy of the
poll I think
and as if they they're like no this is
totally legitimate this is a real thing
yeah this is
this is real this is even more real this
is real if you want a boat legit if you
want to vote for bonehead of the week do
not forget to subscribe here at the Tony
Michaels podcast you can vote every
single week
for bonehead of the week right here on
the community tab you can also vote on
Twitter at Tony Michaels pod follow the
pond account over on Twitter you can
vote there if they get the threads to
where we can put a poll there I'll pull
the poll from Twitter [__] Elon and I'll
put it on threads that way you all have
to go get a threads account to go vote
over there
and then you can watch bone end of the
week every single week on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels just follow us over
there on Facebook you watch live live
live you're a Bonafide conservative
you can also watch it on
to which it's free to follow us on
Twitch if you're not following us on
Twitch already go over to twitch.tv
slash the Tony Michaels hit the follow
button it's free if you want to
subscribe it's free if you have a Prime
account and we still get a couple bucks
hey go over time your Amazon Prime
account to your Twitch account link the
two give us the one free subscription
you get with Amazon gaming you get
commercial free viewing over there you
get to participate in the chat it's wild
stuff over there on Twitch check it out
twitch.tv slash D Tony Michaels if you
want to know how you can tie your Twitch
account to your Amazon account just go
to thetonymichaels.com that's the Tony
michaels.com the directions are there
Gabe Sanchez you're gonna have oh what
was that today you said or tomorrow
this is the one with the with the the
fellatio blow right okay this is one
where you're wearing a beard oh man this
is the one with fellatio blow get it get
it so go to patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez or go to what was thatshow.com
it takes you directly to the patreon
page but a page patreon.com I am Gabe
Sanchez check out what's going on over
there maybe you'll get a quick I got a
sneak peek of fellatio a little little
preview of something
I've also got I'm going to do a one on
Barbie and Ted Cruz and then I'll
probably end up doing one on uh our
little boy RFK Jr here because I haven't
done one yet on him and I feel like I
gotta just like yeah on everything right
you got to do something especially when
he's bench pressing 40 pounds three
times
it's really wild stuff really stop wild
stuff so go check out patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez for all the extras of what
was that show what was that show.com
while you're on patreon you might as
well visit my page this weekend I'm
gonna do a special thing we're gonna do
a rant this weekend but we're gonna talk
about a new workshop that I want to do
so I want you guys to come and
participate come give me suggestions
we'll talk about it we're gonna have a
conversation about what you guys want
out of like a democracy Workshop a
couple times a month over on my patreon
page so go to patreon.com the Tony
Michaels at patreon.com
Michaels we'll see this weekend on that
and we'll see on Monday we got Tennessee
Brando he's gonna come talk about his
great country music his actual good
country music and he's been writing uh
and producing so don't forget to come on
Monday and listen and hear Tennessee
Brando describe how he comes up with
these great songs that he has yeah don't
forget to do that Tennessee Brando
Brando on Monday have a great weekend be
safe we'll see on Monday same time same
place Surf's Up [__] you've
been listening to the Tony Michaels
podcast in your face commentary of
current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__]
[Music]
Murphy's mealborn head ass Beacon
hey y'all it's me Adam the artist
I uh
I'm gonna level with you here I don't
agree with the politics of Jason Aldean
in any way but I got a call from the
record execs this morning they said that
uh he's trending really well and if we
want to see some higher Impressions and
some uh some retweets stuff like that we
really ought to do a cover of a Jason
Aldean song and I thought well
Impressions is what I care about most so
let's do this you know what I mean so uh
please share it away this is Jason
Aldean's new hit uh it's called Sun
downtown
we got no protests or civil unrest never
took a goddamn cover test and we can all
read but we don't do it God and trucks
valued higher than a new Corvette yeah
we all wear boots can we love you shoot
and we root for the cops to stop people
like you this is a son now
oh baby it's the sun downtown
better never let the sun go down
your brother or the guns come out
that's true that I am ignorant on most
of this a couple folks for some reason
called me a bigot let us sweat a lot
yeah I sing them loud even though I
didn't write the [__] I'm singing about
I just read the words and say yeah that
one's good as long as it applies
[Music]
oh baby it's a sundown
time better never let the sun go down
foreign
thank you